e
tu as vu ce qui se passe là tout un
monde aux côtés de quoi la radio ou à la
télé les journaux tout le monde enfin à
l'autre mais oui ce matin chez lui au
précis m'attends à tout moment à l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu trois
camps en ligne là il aura faim tuerie en
parler aussi myocean par un beau fils en
bas ça veut dire que tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
voici le nouvel épisode tout le monde en
parle avec thierry ardisson
[Applaudissements]
corty
alia
[Applaudissements]
izia
mais l'hymne
boli
[Applaudissements]
un vrai public de tel
cahors dit
sur elle
patrick savatier
[Applaudissements]
elle brasse
elie semoun
jean glavany
[Applaudissements]
à une fille
qena temps
et daniel picouly bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission la plus copiée du paf vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle alors tout moment pas déconner
c'est lui qui voit si l'on n'agit
[Applaudissements]
la vie
là
j'ai hâte de faire la promotion de cette
usine a énormément besoin de ta
promotion thierry parce que maintenant
sans toit sans toi la salle est un peu
vide à nancy je te jure les jantes et
coutumes prescripteurs en accueillir de
théâtre ballet voir sexe magouille et
culture générale au théâtre du gymnase
avec avec daniel russo pascal sellem
mado maurin géraldine bonnet guérin
38 boulevard bonne nouvelle 42 46 79 79
vous demandez evelyne à la caisse et
puis acheté des places réservé y amener
du monde des amis
des coûts des produits en guinée donc au
moins un email pour le mouvement
baptiste les baptistes vaincrons parce
que moi je te remarquer l'émission quand
ça passe des rowdies je regarde c'est la
nuit et tu commences à te branler un peu
que les gens bougent
ouais c'est plutôt celle ci avant on
était sur les nerfs
voire plus tard il a cligné des yeux
d'enculés on la refait alors que
maintenant les gens fouillent dans le
net était plus cool je suis pas assez
dur tu es plus cool non sinon on espère
qu'avec un troc ou les cta lien audio
s'il ya beaucoup de ça c'est encore
autre chose
alors vous savez qu'il ya une tradition
dans cette émission c'est de diffuser
chaque semaine les meilleurs moments de
la semaine précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean luc noël
magnéto serge trou il s'épuise à reims
ce soir c'est pourquoi c'est pas parce
que vous avez votre émission à la elle
s'est épanouie elle a un côté salah elle
ne devrait pas garder un peu copié loïk
le floch prigent et beaucoup de
révélations dans votre livre vous dites
j'espère on hypocrisie les numéro deux
derrière balade et la russie je l'aimais
je le mets dans cet ordre
il faudrait que la crevette le bouquet
reviennent en bretagne il ya une
disparition de la crevette en bretagne
chez moi considéré avec je suis obligée
d'aller un peu plus loin pour la paix
chez je sois des charmes
quand vous parlez de crohn en charmant
alors je le dis pour loïc a l'air de
beaucoup s'intéresser à vous vous êtes
travesti mais pas opéré et vous dites ne
va pas couper le téléphone l'électricité
à la rame et vous dites quand vous
parlez de vous une femme ne mate pas
autant le paquet des sommes que moi j'ai
ce vice d'ailleurs pour lui faire le
coup de la crevette la famille le mec
toujours la même façon plutôt qu'un mec
de mille façons un terran minec à
rhinebeck art group of midnight
c'est plus sympa vous ai vue à poil
devant la loi longtemps
oui vous avez une photo de vacances
ferrer c'est bien ravir à fait
convaincant s'en soit poil sur une plage
tout le monde le voit les photos de face
et vous les avez vous vous êtes avec les
filles
à ou alors
[Musique]
ouais je joue extrême alors le dalaï
lama est de passage à paris eric oui le
président république
si vous le recevez la chine annuler une
commande de 80 airbus comme je suis en
cohabitation je charge le premier
ministre si brigitte nielsen
à
alors après vous devenez animatrice chez
berlusconi demande d'avis et adriana
voilà elle a un souffle adoré je
n'aurais jean laborit j'aurais pluriel
parce que j'ai joué je me sentir sociaux
c'est un prix que j'ai gagné ça ok
alors
lukas part il ya eu sylvester stallone
[Musique]
génial énorme énorme
la loisne
là
c'est souvent là
el bared
j'en ris
alors vous savez qu'à la fin de
l'émission il ya toujours un blind test
vous venez de le voir ce soir c'est un
blind test spécial poil c'est à dire les
chanteurs et les chanteuses ont des brus
stage des barbes et d'e books pour
arbitrer ce blind test j'ai fait appel
un homme dessus de tout soupçon
il arrive avec ses deux juges de touche
voici manger avaient les yeux bordés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monseigneur
gauthier bon alors philippe corti avant
de passer au jeu idiot je vais en
expliquer la règle donc ce soir c'est le
bilboquet hall lol
ce qui explique que vous soyez tous
habillés henri iii avec ses mignons
c'est le service public et les missions
un petit peu culturel aussi il faut bien
le dire
donc ce soir vous allez jouer au
bilboquet didier musique maestro
le jeu est très simple attention
attention le bilboquet
mach attention
jamais
oh
j'ai vu qu'il a
et maintenant gagner
bravo l'europe bravo philippe merci et
rendez-vous tuteur problème des
spéciales toile l'e-book les moustaches
et barbes pour les chanteurs et
chanteuses
merci à vous jacques est maintenant bien
en victime
[Applaudissements]
y'a un métier bonsoir bonsoir alors avec
laurent baffie et vous ce soir on a les
deux plus gros succès de la scène
parisienne en ce moment sacha baffie
donc commandé un peignoir sur mesure
entre prochaine il ya en peignoir a très
bien il dépend tout voilà donc vous ces
joyeuses pâques de jean poiret mis en
scène par bernard murat avec caroline
sihol barbara schulz monique tarbès vous
et le théâtre danse et le théâtre des
variétés boulevard montmartre exactement
le même boulevard qu que laurent un an
la pièce a été créée en 1980 par jean
poiret ah j'oubliais un truc attention
ces prêts
vous messieurs vous n'échapperez à rien
alors c'est une pièce sur l'adultère en
fait mais ya pas de l'adultère toujours
comme toujours chez poiret où j'ai fait
n'est le monsieur est plus en flagrant
délit d'intention seulement de mauvais
là la tension ht le pitch oui fait le
pitch alors vous séduisez barbara schulz
voulait inviter à prendre un dernier
verre à la maison et à ce moment là
votre épouse caroline silhol qui
soi-disant absente pour le week-end de
pâques
elle revient elle revient à cause d'une
grève des aiguilleurs
elle revient il l'a sa part dans un
délire absolu
vous inventez au quart de tour à
mensonges et puis un mensonge en amène
un autre et ça se termine dans un délire
absolu intégral absolue
amine cents la folie de poiret quoi la
marque seat quoi la folie sur l
exclusion lui de plus en plus fous alors
quand vous avez vu la pièce la première
fois ce monde la création détient
accompagnée par claude rich ray et sur
le trottoir en sortant vous étiez mort
de rire tous les deux et vous avez dit
j'aimerais bien jouer cette pièce je lui
dis je la jouerai ouais je les jouais et
vous l'avez je vais à temps après ouais
c'est très jubilatoire un de jouer ce
personnage non ce formidable parce qu'on
peut on peut se vautrer dans tout ce
qu'on n'a pas droit de faire dans la vie
c'est à dire qu'on peut aller se vouent
retrait dans la lâcheté dans la mauvaise
foi sont je suis là c'est le mensonge
élevé au rang d'art suprême coincer le
van gogh du bon son quand même ça roule
pour vous un homme à lui c'est pas mal
mais j'ai des bons souvenirs de
mensonges quand ça se passe très bien
donc c'est bourré se passe très bien ce
n'est pas le cas malheureusement de tous
les théâtres compte tenu de ma salle à
manger comment sera difficile c'est un
peu difficile il faut se dépêcher en
plus parce que c'est seulement jusqu'au
31 décembre et ce à quoi qu'il arrive
c'est fini après y'a pas de tourner faut
bien dire j'en ai fait l on est allé
faire été fait
un an après c'est la reprise de l'école
des femmes de molière que j'ai créée à
avignon cet été
ah oui ça me donnera l'occasion de vos
invités alors mais avec lui encore
quelques petits trucs de votre enfant ce
qu'on n'a pas bien s'élevait à 1 10ème
de choses là la rêver bon bah écoutez
d'accord et voilà donc je vous conseille
moi je les ai vu la pièce est vraiment
bien c'est ce qu'on peut dire du
boulevard sous acide ins et re-non saint
c'est très surréaliste un petit peu oui
oui c'est formidable très inspiré le var
je veux bien qu'on appelle ça du
boulevard mais si tu est vraiment élevé
au rang d'art sur rien c'est du boulot
comme feydeau et du boulevard joyeuses
pâques
[Musique]
on va parler de choses un petit peu plus
sérieuse oui dans son article du point
la semaine dernière bernard henri lévy
rapporté une discussion qu'il avait eu
avec des amis new-yorkais pour savoir ce
qu'il faudrait faire à l'emplacement du
world trade center enfin des tours
jumelles d'un accord il est lisse qu'on
parle théâtre qui va total des deux ânes
à partir nous avons on peut le signaler
parce que la redoutable
une fois de plus c'est lamentable je
sais si je l'avais déjà dit et quelques
portables
ma femme qui me pour ma première très
gentil maïs est lamentable alors donc
bernard henri lévy dans sa dernière
chronique du point rapporté une
discussion qu'il avait eu avec des amis
new-yorkais pour savoir ce qu'il
faudrait faire à l'endroit où étaient
les tours jumelles du world trade center
est-ce qu'il faut laisser le lieu vide
est-ce qu'il rêvait c'est une ruine
comme mia à sarajevo la bibliothèque
incendiée de sarajevo hiroshima
il ya deux écoles peut-être faut-il
laisser une trace des quelque chose je
ne sais pas un morceau de ferraille qui
serait symboliserait c'est des choses
qui a eu lieu qui est terrible je crois
surtout qu'il faut qu'il faut
reconstruire la vie là dessus et je
crois que les partisans d'un parent d'un
musée d'un mémorial vous pensez que
c'est mieux de reconstruire quelque
chose qui t'a avait crois que
malheureusement la fin malheureusement
ou heureusement le mémorial le musée
idée dans la tête de chacun d'entre nous
et je crois qu'on peut on n'oubliera
jamais cette image là donc est ce que
bon ça veut pas dire qu'il faut oublier
il n'est pas question d'oublier
je me demande si quand même la meilleure
arme contre ce terrorisme qui le
terrorisme ça veut aussi dire terreur
est ce que parce que la terreur serait
de supprimer nos vies et la manière dont
nous vivons jeu peut-être faudrait-il au
contraire faire reconstruire la vie
d'une manière encore plus puissante mais
peut-être la vie vit pas forcément le
symbole de l'économie ou du fric
quelque chose d'autre oui peut-être
c'est ça qu'il faut faire non moi je
pense
c'est bien
un parent passait bien pour les les gens
qui veulent absolument reconstruire les
tours à l'identique on peut peut-être
les femmes en sous sol pour des raisons
de sécurité alors pierre getti vous
réagissez comme ans à cette idée qui se
développe en france depuis quelques
temps qui consiste à dire que bon ce qui
s'est passé il ya un mois cette semaine
c'est bien entendu effroyable mais que
l'embargo américain finalement sur
l'irak a déjà fait des centaines de
milliers de morts que ce sont eux les
américains qui ont inventé ben laden
pour virer les les russes d'afghanistan
qu'ils ont défendu israël au mépris des
droits de l'homme souvent et delahaye de
la justice est ce que pour vous cette
attitude qui se développe en france
actuellement cinéma titude raisonnable
ou munich oise c'est vrai que l'amérique
armes et les talibans pour [ __ ] sur la
gueule des russes c'est clair bon
maintenant les talibans on se retourne
contre eux qu'on le veuille ou non
quoiqu'il pu faire les américains c'est
tout de même cette image n'est pas
acceptable je veux dire que cette cet
acte là je suis absolument désolé je
peux pas je peux pas l'accepter même si
je peux comprendre qu'un certain nombre
de choses ne sont pas résolus dans le
monde et qu'une partie de ces choses
sont de la responsabilité aussi de
l'amérique mais pas seulement
oui mais pas seulement il ya aussi les
responsabilités deux principaux
protagonistes est aussi responsabilité
d'un certain nombre d'états qui sont des
états confessionnels comme israël et
jure que nous avons nous la chance de
vivre dans un état dans une république
démocratique laïque et on a fait la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
c'est extrêmement différents je ne
dirais pas comme monsieur berlusconi qui
n'aura pas qu'ils ne ratent pas une
équipe vraiment les aligne les unes
derrière les autres les conneries que
nous serions forcément supérieur nous
aux autres bien sûr que nous sommes
simplement différent alors cette
différence de nous permettre d'accepter
la différence de l'autre sauf si l'autre
emploie des moyens qui n'acceptent plus
notre propre différence la démocratie ne
peut tolérer que ce qui la tolèrent et
là on a largement franchi les bornes
alors
non rien ne peut excuser ce qui s'est
passé à new york le 11 septembre rien
même si toute une série de choses
restent à régler nous sommes bien
d'accord là dessus je suis moi par
exemple je suis juif je ne supporterais
pas compte qu'on liquide l'état d'israël
mais je ne supporte pas non plus l'état
de délabrement de dénuement et d'errance
dans laquelle se trouve aujourd'hui le
peuple palestinien voilà
qui gère tout j'ai emmené mon idée que
pensez vous de cette idée de larguer en
même temps sur l'afghanistan des bombes
pour tuer les talibans et des vivres
pour nourrir les autres vous voulez mais
ce que j'en étais summum de la barbarie
on était au summum de là on est au
summum delà du ridicule si on peut
employer un mot aussi dérisoire pour
quelque chose d'aussi tragiques à la
fois en balance des bombes sur des
choses qu'il faut probablement je le dis
très honnêtement détruits moi j'ai vu un
reportage ya pas très longtemps sur m6
sur les talibans et sur ce que font les
talibans en afghanistan
c'est proprement indéfendable on ne
parle pas que des femmes d'ailleurs
quand les gens passent dans les stades
avec des fouets pour interdire aux
spectateurs de rire de sourire et qu'on
arrête le match pour exécuter des gens
sur la pelouse lieu de jouer au football
mais on peut honnêtement on peut mal
défendre ça c'est indéfendable
en même temps bien sûr qu'il faut
détruire ça peut-être aujourd'hui on en
est avec des bombes
il faudra peut-être s'arranger pour
détruire par d'autres moyens en même
temps elle a bien je ne sais pas je
balançais une bombe à droite et puis un
collège militaire à gauche et on sait
pas quoi dire quand on est quand même
dans un
c'est la première fois où il ya un petit
souci d'humanité pendant un bombardement
aussi donc ça va aussi un côté positif
même si l'image de monde sans jouer
c'est le moment du bombardement de leurs
actes et pas eu toutes ces questions et
on aurait peut-être pu balancer des unes
des colis de vivres humanitaires un peu
avant de balancer des bombes
c'est à dire il ya quelques mois ou
années on n'est pas obligé d'attendre la
dénonciation comme est là pour aider des
peuples qui n'ont rien on peut faire ça
avant
[Applaudissements]
du coup on va beaucoup parler ici de la
taxe la taxe tobin qui consiste à
prélever un petit pourcentage sur les
flux monétaires internationaux personne
évidemment a voulu faire la taxe tobin
même l'inventeur tobin ne veut plus en
entendre parler
finalement faute de payer la taxe tobin
accident va peut-être être obligés de
payer la taxe ben laden d'une certaine
façon ce sera plus cher oui c'est très
étonnant cette histoire de taxe tobin
d'heure parce qu'évidemment bon le
raisonnement immédiat vous convient pas
évidement un succès sur ses énormes
masses d'argent on prend une toute
petite partie 0,00 je sais pas quoi et
puis on aide le monde à vivre moins mal
ça semble l'évidence même bien il ya une
levée de boucliers bouclier contre ça
qui est absolument consternante alors
peut-être c'est pas le bon moyen moi je
sais rien je suis pas un économiste mais
on s'est dit quand même que je prends
prenons une toute petite partie c'est
uniquement mais c'est même assez mal la
langue appartient bien qu'annoncée même
pas l'argent qui appartient à quelqu'un
c'est que c'est que dalle
voilà il ya même ça s'ils sont pas vos
visites visiblement un impensable à
bouger c'est un peu désespérant quand
même je ne cherchais pas parce que on
parle beaucoup de ces valeurs
occidentales
il serait parait-il supérieur aux autres
et bien peut-être faudrait-il se poser
un certain nombre de questions sur ses
valeurs et en tout cas si l'on se posait
des questions sur ses valeurs au moins
sur leur respect et sur leur sens et
peut être qu'aujourd'hui on perd un peu
la notion du sens et du fonds pour de la
forme et pour du bruit du bruit de la
fureur qui ne signifie rien comme disait
shakespeare ce bruit cette fureur me
font peur
[Applaudissements]
alors comme vous êtes plutôt un mec
simple sympa etc
on va vous faire une interview de stars
[Musique]
le moral revient le bain fils à la tête
donc c'est l'interview alain delon donc
c'est la mode c'est la mode lamentable
c'est ces misérables alors qu'au début
de chaque au début de chaque réponse oui
vous devez dire pierre arditi pense que
bien un oui d'accord bakassi je
comprends alors légaliser les drogues
douces vous trouvé l'idée stupéfiante où
vous trouvez stupéfiante qu'on l'ait pas
encore fait
il y avait environ il pense que c'est
plutôt stupéfiants qu'on n'ait pas au
moins essayer de le faire voilà votre
conception du luxe c'est boire du coca
dans un verre en cristal ou du petrus
dans un gobelet en plastique
ah bah alors écoutez ça va la main non
non non
bah pierre arditi pense que le luxe
suprême serait tout de même de boire du
petrus et pas dans une coupe en cristal
mais dans un wagon dans lequel on peut
faire tourner ce vin pourront chacun
pour les arômes à ce que le petrus et
1,20 à meerab voilà ce qu'il pense
pierre hardy
[Applaudissements]
pour taper la frime vous préféré rouler
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
dix doigts en tracteur avec un canon il
préfère rouler 10 bornes en tracteur
avec un canon mais qui gére arditi pour
vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro pour
pierre arditi c'est évidemment
l'interdiction des mariages homos
kinnock le plus bien entendu bien voilà
on faire du social vous pensez qu'il
faut augmenter les salaires ou diminuer
le temps de travail via pierre arditi et
très emmerder mais il arriva il va
répondre
il va répondre je ne peux pas répondre
aussi que trut mange même pierre arditi
dans même pierre arditi n'est pas pierre
arditi pense que il est pas forcément
obligatoire de réduire le temps de
travail
peerates qui pense qu'il serait bon de
d'augmenter certains salaires parce que
ça fait repartir d'économique ça permet
aux gens de vivre moins mal
il ya personne qui pense qu'il ya peut
être un moyen terme à trouver entre une
durée du temps de travail qui serait pas
codifié à coups de serpe un avis ne peut
pas codifié à coups de serpe et le
travail c'est aussi la vie mais pierre
arditi pense qu'effectivement surtout
pour des gens qui gagnent peu leur vie
c'est qu'il voit assez souvent même au
cours de la sienne de vie de pierre
arditi pense quand même que il serait
mieux que le gens qui gagnent peu
d'argent en gagne un peu plus allemand
ferait pas de mal voilà ce que pense
pirates
des solutions là ça tombe bien il est
chaud il adore dire son nom
jouissant la wii alors on va parler du
commerce du sexe
êtes vous pour la réouverture des
maisons closes ou pour la fermeture des
boîtes à partouzes pierre arditi car
dira on est dans la merde qui
franchement la pierre arditi les pour
ont beaucoup je suis pour la chimie pour
la réouverture des boîtes est partout
[Applaudissements]
n'importe quoi par don minimal danner
qu'il faut s'excuser
inventeur il le fait tous les soirs dans
g8 a qui doivent le prouver pour garder
celle que vous aimez
est-ce que vous préféreriez l'enfermer
dans un talent et où la sortir dans les
clubs échangistes je serais capable de
faire le pire arditi serait capable de
faire les deux pour garder celle qu'il
aime parce qu'il a vraiment aucune envie
de la perdre et donc il pourrait
l'enfermer dans un palais si elle le
voulait bien où la trimballer dans un
club échangiste si c'était le seul moyen
de la garder pour le club échangiste il
le ferait s'il y avait pas d'autres
moyens déjà demandé tu vois il est
d'accord eh bien ils chérissent le monde
hier midi au théâtre
pas de lui
j'espère
alors après la tournée mondiale de la
comédie musicale notre dame de paris
elle revient dans la capitale au théâtre
mogador avec une nouvelle esmeralda
c'est chirol
[Applaudissements]
il
voilà cette jolie alors votre maman
c'est ma passion
[Musique]
alors dit benson dans la connu au cinéma
on l'a connu au théâtre l'inconnu
faisant évidemment de la chanson et elle
a publié dernièrement un livre aux
éditions du rocher qui s'appelle prière
d'amour qui sont en deuxième livre avec
ses plus beaux poèmes d'amour voilà une
petite prière à faire tous les jours et
qui parle de dieu qui parle de
spiritualité alors à part ça quand même
on l'a connue avec allain bougrain
dubourg après évidemment
[Musique]
on l'a connue avec richard berry et puis
après
[Musique]
bon
on a connu avec andré djaoui puis après
merde
m
est ce que parce que quand elle fait un
dîner thamer al issa aux gens
systématiquement non c'est une chance
mais si tu viens écoute
c'était en 1978 à paris
votre vrai prénom c'est jennifer non
c'est mon prénom mais c'est pas mon vrai
prénom ont choisi là elle te déteste
méfie toi tu es réel de départ vous avez
utilisé on vous a baptisé de jennifer
oui et j'ai choisi après un an et bright
qui est et shirel shirel qui veut dire
le champ vers dieu voilà c'est ça vous
êtes votre merde c'est une bonne mère
s'était convertie renom je me suis
converti vous vous êtes converti vous
insolent père est juif et ma mère n'est
pas joué et vous vous avez décidé de
vous convertir d'accord l'institut déjà
star avant votre naissance puisque à
cause de vous votre mère enceinte a dû
quitter le tournage d'un film d'andré
hunebelle où elle refusait refusé de
montrer ses seins j'étais encore ans en
fer avec david hallyday david hallyday
quand il est venu j'ai raconté plein de
trucs sur son enfance qui savaient pas
ouais bah oui j'ai eu un procès qu'elle
a qu'elle avait regagné et au moment du
procès il était tellement mécontent les
producteurs du film qu'elle avait quitté
qu'ils ont ressorti des photos d'elle
nue dans playboy et ça vous avez vu ces
photos
oui abanda vous apprends rien
monsieur alors six jours après votre
naissance des gens en photo dans france
soir vous êtes déjà une dans le petit
costume de baptême de votre papa vous en
souvenez pas de ça non j'ai pas de
costumes baptême mais bon tant pis si
vous voulez un six jours six jours après
votre naissance est en photo dans france
soir
oui mais je suis enfin j'ai pas des
gypaètes baptême la crise et le chômage
si vous rentrez dans le métier il faut
apprendre vivait là ça fait sa chemise
on bosse ensemble un au rang de dieu
ménages mais moi j'ai vu la pièce je
vous ai trouvé très charmant derrière le
petit rideau rouge t'as pas vu quand
j'étais au milieu et je voulais dire
c'était mon anniversaire mais j'ai pas
voulu manquer
oui parce qu'ils le demandent et le
passe pas on célèbre les anniversaires
des gens tous les aspects et il faut que
les gens à leurs papiers est ce qu'il
est trop dure que heureusement tout
n'est pas fait parce que moi je regrette
bien je l'adorais falla mois est amer
alors hop et la chanson rattrapage à un
an dont vous partez aux usa vous revenez
à quel âge en france à six ans pour
faire parce que vérité ouais facile et
alors fait alors appel à quel âge vous
partez en israël à 18 ans à 18 ans c'est
pourquoi elle répond c'est pourquoi
parce que pour rechercher mon identité
mes racines
ah ouais voilà et là vous êtes converti
au judaïsme
oui je vais t'appeler shirel exact qui
vous appelle encore jennifer aujourd'hui
ma mère ouais c'est normal il malmène la
peine un peu je comprends vous a plutôt
choisi le côté de votre père quand même
non pas du tout mais je chante c'est
déjà un truc
du côté de ma mère non mais je oui j'ai
adopté la religion mais bon c'est ils
ont fait le choix de se marier entre eux
et de me donner la liberté ben je les
prises avant d'être converti à la
religion hébraïque vous aviez une
religion ben non je crois je me suis
toujours sentie juive enfin lorsque
votre merde oui dans le judaïsme pas
comme ça ah bon oui c'est noir quand
elle s'est mariée avec richard berry
c'était rites hindouistes oui pareil
j'étais pas invité c'est rigolo rites
hindouistes était sur la plage et des
petites fleurs des banderoles blanches
comme ça il nous a raconté sainz charité
très content alors là bas donc à tel
aviv où aller à l'école de musique et
vous participez au fait un disque avec
un groupe s'appelle sol tune singer donc
déjà beaucoup de beaucoup de ouais quoi
non mais vous avez trouvé ça parce que
c'est un truc ça vient comme moi qui le
disque ça s'est pas vendu ni quoi ni
cassé vol n'ont pas très bien vous vous
dites comment j'étais toi comment vous
savez ça ben comment vous savez mercier
c'est tout ce que je veux encore
je les garde
mais comment vous savez ça je les
collectionne oui alors vous êtes
retrouvé comment au casting de notre
dame de paris ça j'étais en vacances et
ma mère m'a dit écoute il cherche une
nouvelle esmeralda leur prépare les deux
chansons et donc je dis ok donc je suis
venu en vacances j'ai préparé les
chansons et puis puis ça a bien marché
au bout de la troisième fois ils m'ont
dit que c'était bon body dont j'ai eu de
la chance génial c'était votre
anniversaire en plus alors aussitôt
après la réponse positive et boire un
coup avec votre mère dans un café qui
s'appelle comment alors là les smeralda
un sens non ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
bizarre
c'est ce qu'on l'ait on a su le
lendemain on a regardé le ticket de
paiement là il y avait écrit l'esmeralda
en croit ses paroles
tout de suite après nombre assez
imprécis donc voilà vous êtes à nouveau
les smeralda faut reconnaître que vous
avez tout à fait le look et le charme
d'esmeraldas et bien bien trouver bravo
bon casting a qu'un problème à chèvres
non c'est vrai lamentable
maintenant c'est pas ça le problème
c'est que le fiancé rester en israël
j'étais venu en nombre
il n'y a pas de problème si quand même
non jallet victime du syndrome véronika
loubry sévices larissa ce n'est pas
l'été avec teriitahoia et puis lui il
était en polynésie et elle était ici et
au bout d'un moment c'est arrivé à
mareva galanter aussi avec son jules qui
était en nouvelle calédonie mais je
m'inquiète vraiment là je vous dis vous
inquiétez pas comment vous faites vous
téléphonez comme une fois par jour ou
téléphonez déjà joué ou non une fois
ouais ouais c'est mieux c'est pas
beaucoup alors pourquoi je sais bien tu
doives bah oui parce que je téléphonais
trop c'est pas bon non plus voilà bien
sûr là attention non mais ils y arrivent
à venir tout le temps et moi je vais je
vais partir donc c'est bon vous
inquiétez pas pour nous c'est sûr ah non
c'est sûr c'est sûr que c'est qu'ici on
peut lancer des appels et tout essayé
j'ai entendu je savais qu'en israël nous
on a une heure de plus et on se couche à
2h30 du matin pour par vos émissions
comme tout le monde en fait samedi soir
il s'agit de la nive c'est magnifique je
salue on était tous très contents pour
votre coupe de cheveux
il ya eu des manifestations de joie dans
tel aviv croyable la barre incroyable
[Musique]
il s'appelle comment votre jules a le
mérite d'être cours du mois gaye
ben voila voila comment gaye lol non
mais c'est pâques des séquences mais ça
veut dire quoi en france est cocu
alors justement c'est donc un hommage à
game gaye
on vous faire une interview par mois
c'est normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes baffie installé à l'éditeur
acteurs cette petite halle ira loin
bien alors par amour est ce que vous
pourriez arrêté de chanter oui oui
vraiment si vous demander d'arrêter de
chanter vous le faites hier qu'il ne
demanderait pas mais si je devais faire
une famille ça ça me sam ce serait
contre contre ça oui j'arrêterai ah
d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous exiler en nouvelle zélande
non parce que je vais habiter en israël
est lui aussi dans un monde ça fait des
années qu'ils espèrent adresse sera fini
pour tourner là bas
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire va faire les seins je ne
connais pas les faits mais si vous lisez
je veux que tes dessins de talia par
exemple ou de bons très pauvre et qu'ils
attendent pour moi mais bon non non non
moi ce que je suis c'est pour lui parce
qu'il regarde l'émission je suis sûr et
je veux savoir
vous feriez pour lui par exemple la
fameuse question clotilde courau est ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes
sales
oui il a de la chance les garçons il n'y
a pas d'hésitation
oui france et s'y étant affaibli ne
brille que cet accord aussi
oui d'ailleurs est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à prendre 20 kilos parce
qu'il aime les rubens parce que je
n'aimerais pas mois après je l'aimerais
palais ça va tu peux vincee nord faisant
maintenant cet hiver s'attira bien parce
qu'un très beau format de visage vous
dit que celle ci entend ce gros q3
m
miam
celle à monclar est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à cacher le corps de
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
oui elle mangeait non ménagers non mais
le cachet très aimée gala du coup je
pense que là bas ils vont aux [ __ ]
c'est un croix
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez killing maîtresse non mais
vous l'aimez pas alors comme ma femme
est d'accord qu'elle vient à manches
cela la rendait heureuse pas du tout
donc par amour vous soyez pas prêtes à
vivre à trois avec la maîtresse par
exemple pourtant dans un kibboutz a
montré de la place ouais c'est vrai mais
non non les clubs échangistes pas montré
tendre amour avec la maîtresse
non on arrive attention on arrive à la
question de la fiche 69 et les messieurs
et là je me méfie parce que c'est vous
qui me posait une question puis voyant
comment vous êtes je suis prêt à tout
d'abord lancé
est-ce que vous avez des rêves vous avez
pas encore accompli et qu elle sentie
comme rêve oui j'aimerais bien produire
un film de long métrage
voilà pas le réaliser puisque j'en
serais sûrement pas capable mais le
produire oui ça me plairait de faire du
long métrage
voilà un peu dans le milieu des boîtes
échangistes
là c'est un truc normalement vous
devriez être d'accord je sais pas moi
mais bon est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à devenir son esclave sexuelle
oui bravo
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à arrêter de fumer a
commencé à fumer non bon oui oui je sais
pas bon pour la voix voilà si en plus je
dois arrêter de chanter et commencent à
fumer en vingt kilos non oui oui haram
en voulez mais a dit luis da camera
regarder
mouillart
paris et maintenant
ouais si patrick sabatier
les hommes
patrick sabatier donc vous venez de
faire votre rentrée sur monte carlo tmc
avec une nouvelle formule de pendant la
pub pendant la pub c'est un talk show
qui est diffusée du lundi au vendredi de
20h35 à 20h55 avec une intégrale le
samedi à 13h30 et il re div tous les
soirs vers minuit on sait comment on
fait on va le faire une fois déjà pour
l'émission alors vous y pratiquer l'art
de l'interview avec une réussite que
beaucoup d'animateurs qu'on voit sur les
chaînes hertziennes en ce moment
pourrait vous enviez vous m'avez invité
dans une émission qui sera diffusée du 5
au 9 novembre dans cette semaine là et
vous m'avez fait dire des choses que je
dis rarement à la télé bravo à toi
la belle-mère de ta mère et puis puis de
même partie de dix ans sans parler des
parents oui je crois que je crois que
vraiment je me suis jamais fait
psychanalyser mais je crois que ça va
voir un psy c'est ce qui ferait que je
raconte hangar et où il faudrait qu'un
jour je fasse un roman là dessus du
rouge en aurait le courage mais c'est
vrai que donc quand mon grand père est
mort
ma grand mère la mère de mon père est
venu habiter chez nous bon et ma mère il
n'est pas tellement mais bon elle a fait
propre à ce qu'elle aimait mon père
évidemment elle aime toujours d'ailleurs
elle a accepté bon alors dans ces cas là
c'est pas grave quand on a des grandes
maisons contre les grandes propriétés on
peut habiter avec les les beaux parents
et ça c'est pas un problème nous mon
père et des travaux publics et déménager
tous les deux ou trois ans alors il est
des endroits où on arrivait à vis de
maisons assez grande et ça posait pas de
problème mais quand on habitait dans un
appartement et ça nous est déjà arrivé
ma grand mère était là au milieu quoi
puis ma grand-mère était quand même pas
quelqu'un de très facile
donc il ya eu moi j'ai vécu toute mon
enfance dans cette tension dans cette
tension mais tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours
c'est c'est quelque chose qui m'a
vraiment flinguer quoi
[Applaudissements]
voilà quelqu'un qui sait bien parler les
gens alors ce qui est incroyable patrick
c'est qu'à l'époque où vous aviez des
prime time sur tf1 10 millions de
téléspectateurs
vous aviez une mauvaise image dans
l'intelligentzia et aujourd'hui vous
fait 20 fois moins de clients et tout le
monde vous adore non ce n'est pas normal
généralement ça se passe comme ça et
beaucoup par exemple pivot une très
bonne image pendant de très nombreuses
années y avait très peu de gens qu'ils
regardaient c'est pas à la fois c'est
pas proportionnel est à la fois on le
comprend c'est vrai il ya une super
image non en ce moment titoune
incroyable est totalement justifié bien
sûr mais c'est vrai que cette émission
avec absolument remarquable que il l'a
fait magnifiquement et c'est vrai qu'il
fait admirablement parler les gens parce
que surtout sur tf1 c'était pas le genre
d'exercice qu'on pratique est là on a le
temps et avec le mélange on arrive à
avoir des confidences avec alors vous
publié chez anne carrière le temps
n'efface pas tout merci et de réserver
votre première visite à la télévision
pour nous et vous êtes obligés de
refaire le truc
avoir en main sur elle alors au début du
livre vous parlez de votre première
gitane sans filtre de la journée vous
dites que ça vous fait tourner la tête
alors premiers aveux sabatier se
défoncent la gitane depuis à peu près 20
ans oui
ouais c'est qu'il ya des trucs qui font
plus tourner la tête quand même mais
déjà la gitane moi ça me suffit pour la
règle mais déjà des délais dès le
premier paragraphe on se rend compte que
veut dire des choses n'ai pas l'habitude
de dire parce que c'est vrai que votre
image étaient plutôt calmes assez lisse
à l'époque et d'un seul coup vous dit
bon je fume des clopes ça me fait mal
mais c'est bon enfin il ya un sabatier
un peu différent de celui que trajet non
c'est parce que bon au moment où j'ai
commencé à écrire d'une part je savais
pas que ça allait devenir un livre et
c'était une période de ma vie c'était
donc en décembre de l'année dernière
après la disparition de mon père je me
suis retrouvé peu de temps avant noël
comme ça en provence on est une maison
et j'étais évidemment pas bien et donc
j'ai commencé à écrire sans dire que ça
allait devenir quoi que ce soit de moi
besoin de me recadrer par rapport à ce
qui était arrivé et tout compte fait
c'était tellement grave pour moi
tellement déstabilisant que je me
foutais de l'image je me foutais de
savoir comment on allait me percevoir de
toute façon c'était pas pour être lu au
départ le livre c'était pour moi d'abord
votre père disparaît ce qui est
extrêmement attaché à lui et c'est une
relation beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
forte que la la relation qu'on a
généralement avec avec son père sa mort
vous a complètement sidérée et c'est
vrai que votre livre c'est beaucoup plus
que des mémoires d'animateurs parce
qu'on sent une vraie 3d mémoire d'annie
madrid c'est surtout pas ça c'est parce
que mon père m'a appris une chose que je
n'ai pas beaucoup retrouver mois dans le
chemin de la télévision et que vous si
vous savez mais après la dignité
il m'a appris à être bien jusque enfin
en ce qui concerne jusqu'aux derniers
mois dernier moment et moi je trouvais
ça extraordinaire de cet exemple par
rapport à toute la lâcheté que j'avais
connu pendant des années avec des gens
enfin pas correct et donc je voulais
aussi lui dire que ça allait je savait
déjà au moment où j'écrivais que ils
allaient terrible terrible banc de
manquer ça continue ouais vous n'êtes
pas remis de sa non mais je pense que
j'en ai parlé avec pierre parce que moi
je crois qu'on se remet jamais vraiment
et de la perte des gens qu'on aime
[Musique]
alors vous venez d'un milieu modeste
mais surtout par une profession instable
parce que chez vous il n'y avait pas de
fiche de paye pas de congés payés vos
parents étaient marchands des quatre
saisons
il avait un stand dans la rue une
charrette une charrette petite charrette
et que tous les soirs il remisait au
garage ouais ouais donc il vivait
vraiment à la semaine quoi oui je dis
dans le livre que l'horizon pour moi
c'était la semaine pour nous c'était la
semaine ce qui d'ailleurs après ne m'a
pas beaucoup troublé quand j'ai fait un
métier aléatoires tels que le nôtre
parce que j'étais habitué à ça la
charrette dans le show mais il y en a
beaucoup en a plein c'est vrai non mais
c'est vrai quand vous débarquez après
chez les gens les bras chargés de
cadeaux tout le monde disait il fait ça
pour faire peuple est en fait vous venez
du peuple donc vous forciez pas beaucoup
non je ne me suis pas forcé avec le
recul je pense que j'ai peut-être plus
aller trop loin
certains moments mais je m'en
n'apercevait pas parce que j'y croyais
mais bon et puis j'avais 20 ans de moins
ouais alors un jour voilà la révélation
un jour vous passez devant un camion
citerne qui rallie à une station service
et vous entendez dans la dans la cabine
la radio et vous prenez conscience de la
magie du média radio et vous dites ça
sera mon métier oui je trouve formidable
que l'on puisse entendre une voix la
même voix un peu partout en france en
faisant des activités différentes et je
me suis dit tiens j'ai j'aimerais
devenir une voix au départ c'était
d'ailleurs la radio qui m'intéressait
beaucoup plus que la télé alors vous
êtes en seconde vous habitez vitry à
l'époque et vous tombé raide dingue de
la radio c'est à dire à l'époque c'était
radio luxembourg encore numéro 1 france
inter vous décidez de passer aux actes
et ce qui est incroyable une espèce de
passion comme ca total
le matin votre père en allant aux halles
chercher ses fruits il vous déposez rue
bayard chez radio luxembourg quoique en
avant d'aller au lycée vous alliez
assister à l'émission de maurice
favières quoi pendant plusieurs années
j'étais comme ça derrière la glace je
regardais favy retravaillé et me laisser
rentrer et puis un jour je
dit je voudrais faire ça comment je peux
faire expliquer moi et il m'a tendu
quelques publicités et et puis j'ai
enregistré ça chez moi j'avais je vais
aménagé un studio de ma cave enfin dans
la cave de mes parents avec un petit
magnétophone grande digue et à tes pas
j'ai ma propre émission de radio dans la
carte et aux parents des premières
radios libres premier auditeur est le
seul d'ailleurs
ouais alors pendant 68 doit vous prenez
conscience de l'importance du média
radio évidemment puisque la radio était
très importante pendant les événements
de 68 et en 70 grande nouveauté vous
faites votre première émission à deux
avec la fille du coiffeur exactement ce
dimanche matin le salon était fermée jeu
un jeu contraignait sympathiquement
j'espère m'enfin tous mes copains à
faire le public est bien de l'été avec
jocelyne la fille du coiffeur c'est
incroyable c'est une espèce de passion
comme ça mais si tu me regardes austruy
voilà à l'émission s'appelait moisson 70
c'était donc en trouver des titres après
oui il ya eu des titres qui
correspondait à ce que je faisais là ça
correspondait un fourre-tout pour tout
c'est triste et lamentable
face à la menthe abl contraire ça allège
un peu ensuite service militaire premier
job surveillant d'externat ensuite
l'économie à assas et leur parallèlement
une espèce de hargne incroyable
j'écrivais à tous les gens dont vous
voyez le nom dans télé 7 jours
tous les tous les producteurs de télé va
leur envoyer des petits mots pour qu'ils
vous pour qu'il vous fasse beau c'est
sans réponse et un jour effectivement le
secrétariat des lianes victor donc à
l'époque c'était la première chaîne
s'était pas tf1 vous parle des visiteurs
du mercredi c'était quoi ça c'était ta
casting qu'ils avaient organisée et on
était à peu près une quarantaine y avait
déjà des jeunes ont très très très connu
et puma fait venir mais parmi parmi les
autres qu'on m'a fait faire un casting
devant une caméra on m'a demandé de
parler des indiens des alliages aurait
parlez-nous des indiens comme ça dans la
caméra et au bout de deux minutes j'ai
entendu une voix qui venait de la régie
qu'il fait très bien merci on vous
écrira aussi du cds et c'est foutu mais
je m'en foutais un petit peu parce que
je voulais faire de la radio surtout et
puis ça s'est passé à mercredi et le
lendemain christophe izard qui était le
producteur de l'émission m'a appelé en
me disant c'est toi qu'on a choisi voilà
vous ai même pas 24 ans et vous
commencez à faire de l'antenne trois
heures de direct le mercredi après midi
chaque semaine effectivement déçu que ce
soit pas de la radio est il assez
quelques temps plus tard vous êtes vous
allé à europe 1 d'abord et ensuite rtl
où vous restez 16 ans à europe 1 je me
fais jeter on me dit tu ne feras jamais
une radio de ta vie tu as une très
mauvaise voie et je suis resté dix huit
ans après rtl et sur cette première
chaîne devenue ensuite tf1 vous faites
vos grandes émissions on peut dire et
dieu sait si si s'il m'arrive de
critiquer publiquement dans la presse
les émissions de mes confrères de temps
en temps vous vos concepts sont très
simples sont très limpide et ils sont
originaux ce qui ne gâche rien et ils
sont résumable c'est vraiment un pitch
ils sont résume à blanc en deux lignes
comment ruiner la carrière d'une
chanteuse en face
acer est toujours très clair et ça c'est
lamentable
non mais c'est vrai que les concepts de
sabatier devrait laisser rêveur les
pompes heures avec pompeuse qui
sévissent aujourd'hui parce que non mais
c'est vrai j'ai de la vérité moi y'a
quelques émissions de vous je dis
sérieusement que j'aurais aimé inventer
le jeu de la vérité par exemple qu'est
ce qui est plus simple en direct mais
t'es un mec sur une scène on a vu
d'abord tout le monde y est passé de
cité qui le premier alain delon janvier
11 janvier 85 voilà donc le mec vient
sur scène vous souvenez quand même cinq
voyages et le public lui pose des
questions en direct c'est très bien ça
avis de recherche par exemple une idée
géniale de partir d'une photo de classe
et de recherches sur tous les gens qui
sont sur la photo que sont ils devenus
c'était génial parce que tu voyais des
potes qui se détester à l'époque au
[ __ ] t'es là comme ça me fait plaisir
c'est un [ __ ] gras
tombé dans les bras il ya des idées à
vous qui sont prises aujourd'hui comme
porte bonheur que j'ai revu il ya pas
longtemps à la télé ça vous fait quoi
quand vous voyez ça franchement qu'on
s'inspire de ce que j'ai fait me gêne
pas trop et quelques passes ça flatte un
peu même mon orgueil maintenant je pense
qu'il ya autre chose à faire mais quand
vous voyez stars à domicile par exemple
se doit vous fatiguez n'ont pas trop non
non franchement parce que ce que j'ai en
tête c'est déjà autre chose
bon le journal de 20h ça va te coûter
plus que 3 4 5 ou des coulisses et puis
après ben voilà lé problème qui commence
en a passé la soirée là dessus mais
c'est vrai quelle affaire chantal goya
dont notre ami baffie parlais à
l'instant alors elle croit chantal goya
mais j'ai appris ça en lisant votre
bouquin elle croit que l'institutrice
qui nous posent des questions est une
comparse en fait manipuler par
l'émission pour couler sa carrière oui
c'est à dire que l a cru qu'on avait
monté le coup à tel point que plusieurs
années après dans une autre émission je
lui ai fait rencontré cette femme qui
existe a évidemment vraiment ma soeur à
partir de là elles se sont rencontrées
bon elle a reconnu qu'elle existait
vraiment faim que c'est elle et quelques
mois après dans une autre émission je
l'entends dire non mais n'a jamais
existé cette femme là c'est à dire que
chantal goya a refait l'histoire parce
que celle ci l'a dérangé tellement que l
à réinventer notre histoire pour être
mieux dans sa tête
en fait je peux le comprendre mais c'est
quand même elle qui a ce soir là
déraillé bah oui elle s'est attaquée à
son public d'une certaine façon d'en bas
je crois qu'elle a réagi comme personne
ne s'y attendait là ça a dérapé parce
que toi tu te rends bien compte du
danger de cette émission quand même très
content c'est que ça pouvait donner sa
chance à un moment donné quand elle a
commencé à à dire je suis une fée et
sert à l ailier a défoncé on peut le
dire maintenant
ce n'est pas mais je me suis posé la
question mais je me souviens que j'avais
question de feeling qui était
interprétée par fabienne thibeault après
je lui dis dans l'oreille je dis si tu
veux on va reprendre l'antenne après
puis on va revenir en étant direct et tu
vas tu excusé et elle m'a dit mais non
je m'en fous je suis comme ça et ce soir
on veut on va le voir tel que je suis et
là ça a été
l'uimm on l'a vue telle qu'elle était et
ça lui a coûté 10 ans des clipse ouais
je sais pas si c'est que ça quand même
n'aurait peut-être pas alors vous après
la fameuse affaire donc la fraude
fiscale c'était quoi l'histoire c'est ça
pour nous monter une société comme on
nous le on nous le demandait puisque on
devait livrer nos programmes comme vous
faites clé en main c'est à dire faire
faire ça et puis on avait demandé à être
société nouvelle c'est à dire à ne pas
payer d'impôts pendant trois ans et ça
nous avait été reconnue jusqu'au moment
où il y eu un contrôle fiscal on nous a
dit attendez depuis trois ans vous ne
payez pas d'app où s'étaient déclarés
mais on ne les paient pas il va falloir
les payer
et bizarrement alors que moi j'aurais dû
dire bon d'accord allez on paye tout de
suite on est rentré dans une guerre
entre le fisc et nous par le tribunal de
nis administratif d'abord puis on a
perdu
voilà voilà oui alors en plus ce qui est
terrible c'est quand vous allez au
tribunal jeudi tout régler vous avez
payé toutes les ds que vous aviez
sensing 15 jours et en quinze jours dans
nos ports milliards et le président du
tribunal dit quatre ans de prison
il laisse passer un petit temps comme ça
il y avec sursis un peu comme jean
pierre foucault dans les millions
mais tu as dit c'est votre dernier mot
moi même j'étais pas très capable d'y
répondre là bon rien à faire du mage
aussi le guérisseur pour laquelle vous
avez été complètement blanchi aussi un
centime problème c'est que ça a pris du
temps quoi vivre raconte exactement
c'est très clair c'est très bien raconté
vous raconter surtout que ce soit vous
avez été emmené au commissariat ont été
fouillés au corps nuit en garde à vue
déféré devant le juge l'homme un matin
mise en examen durée 42 mois est ce que
je raconte ma gym quand même pour un
hacker de 42 mois la mise en examen est
ce que je raconte surtout fait que
l'émission a été enregistrée au début du
mois de décembre que la cassette a été
donnée à tf1 avant diffusion pour le 28
décembre que tf1 donc là théoriquement
visionner qu'elle a laissé l'émission
passé qu elle trouvait ça tout à fait
normal que les gens ont écrit pour avoir
l'adresse de ce match que je n'avais
évidemment pas donné à l'antenne et que
tf1 m'a demandé d'inscrire sur l'écran
mois de janvier la dre the image alors
que tf1 à ce moment-là ça lave les mains
et il n'est absolument pas jugé comme
coresponsable oui vous dit effectivement
que tf1 s'en lave les mains je vous êtes
convoqué au 14e étage on vous dit votre
concept est pas bon vous devriez vous
reposer six mois
vous partez sans indemnités
un blizzard cinq ans maintenant vous
dites je n'avais pas envie de compter
des petites cuillers non ils ont fait
une rupture de contrat il considérait
que de toute façon je gagne trop
d'argent
c'est pour ça que tf1 a voulu pendant
longtemps ils pensaient que j'étais
l'état dans l'état je faisais le
vendredi soir je gagnais donne beaucoup
d'argent j'avais un chiffre d'affaires
important
j'en parle dans le libre on nous l'a
proposé cet argent on l'a pas volée on
le méritait il y avait 140 personnes qui
travaillent avec nous et tout compte
fait c'était un système commercial
auquel j'appartenais et à un moment
donné il ya un des deux partenaires qui
a décidé de fête d'interrompre le
contrat je n'ai pas eu la présence
d'esprit qui a eu plus tard dechavanne
ou plus tard de la rue et sur cette
antenne d'attaqué tf1 et j'ai laissé
passer en pensant que plus tard nous
allions nous remettre ensemble
1 mais ya pas eu de plus tard il tombe
bien [ __ ] sur ce mot vient avec
[Musique]
votre image a été très abîmée ensuite
c'était très abîmée par les rumeurs par
des gens qui avaient tout à fait intérêt
à ce que je sois plus dehors que dedans
des concurrents si possible en qui ben
non on va les concurrents de voile à
fouquières salingue et sébastien drucker
voilà les concurrents de patrick lorsque
vous souhaitez tout n'est pas exact je
voulais qu'elle n'a jamais trop pas
signé la presse en justice vous dites
dans ce genre d'affaires on est perdant
dès que le journal a paru tout à fait
vrai à quand même je voudrais dire une
chose je vais quand même citer ce soir
quelque chose que je trouve
particulièrement dégueulasse
et si c'est ma dernière mission de
télévision - je leur ai dit à la fin du
mois d'août de cette année
j'étais donc en provence là où j'ai ma
maison avec ma mère et avec mes enfants
avec ma famille et ma mère dans le
village a été appelé par le libraire qui
lui a dit écoutez c'est vraiment
dégueulasse regarder france dimanche et
il y avait des photographes de france
dimanche qui était allé photographier la
tombe de mon père dans un petit village
de banlieue j'ai donc appelé le
rédacteur en chef directeur de la
rédaction de ce journal qui s'appelle
monsieur nicolas pigasse et je lui ai
dit qu'il pouvait venir face à man à la
télévision pour discuter de sa prétendue
conscience journalistique je plains
d'ailleurs ses parents parce que quand
il était bébé il devait être un beau
petit gamin et c'est devenu un bon
dégueulasse alors moi j'estime que de
toute façon je sais que les cimetières
ce sont des endroits publics
mais quand mon père est mort c'était une
chose intime je ne l'ait pas dit c'était
entre nous c'était on avait envie d'être
tranquille d'aller photographier la
tombe de quelqu'un pour le mettre dans
ce journal pro vente d exemplaires en
plus je trouve ça honteux
voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'album commence votre traversée du
désert vous dites dans votre bouquin
c'est même la première phrase du bouquin
vous dites j'ai essayé de revenir sur la
une la deux la trois 1 2 3 0
alors les gens vous disent tu fais de la
télé tu travailles nom de quoi tu te
plains de rien de rien mais le temps
n'efface pas tout c'est le titre de
votre livre
oui le temps n'efface pas tous
heureusement qu'ils les fassent pas tous
heureusement qu'ils ne fassent pas les
très bons souvenirs que j'ai puis je
pense que bien sûr il ya des gens que je
trouve plus respectables et tout ça
c'est y est excusez moi de le répéter
mais c'est lié à ce que j'ai vécu donc
d'un côté la dignité
une façon de se comporter dans la vie
une façon d'être une façon de gagner sa
vie on m'a appris le travail on me suis
tu travailles tu vas réussir
je me suis aperçu que c'était pas que ça
non plus la réussite
et puis d'un autre côté des intrigues
des stratégies de lâcheté des lobbys des
relations donc bon tout ça est assez
bouleversant mais ce que je n'ai pas
compris moi est ce que je ne comprends
toujours pas encore et je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne comprennent pas
si vous voulez je suis pris dans une
certaine ambiguïté dans ma tête
premièrement j'estime que rien mais du
on m'a élevé comme ça donc rien de
méduses je vois pas pourquoi je ne
prétendrai avoir plus que n'importe
lequel l'antenne que ce soit tf1 france
2 france 3
moralement je me dis bon bah si j'ai
quelque chose de bien pourquoi pas mais
je ne vois pas non plus pourquoi tout
m'est interdit vrai c'est à dire que je
dis à temps en quoi je suis moins bon
que sébastien drucker foucault lumbroso
et c est là sylvain brossaud peut-être
c'est vrai c'est vrai alain brezault je
vous avoue met donc c'est là où je ne
comprends pas une personne comme d'un
autre côté je me dis pour prendre cette
chaîne sur laquelle par exemple des gens
sur l'a2 j'en ai vu beaucoup qui m'ont
dit on est moins bien et ils viennent
avec nous sauf que en haut il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui veut pas je le
dis dans le livre ya toujours un mais il
ya toujours un directeur de cabinet un
chargé de communication pour chuchoter
dans l'oreille du grand patron prenons
pas de risques on sait jamais les
attendait c'est ça qui m'énerve
quel est le risque de prendre un
animateur mais c'est quoi un animateur
c'est quand même assez d'eux
tuer laurent moi nous sommes des
saltimbanques
on est des artistes attend on va pas
changer le monde c'est quoi le risque
moi je comprends pas pourquoi tu es
vraiment pas notre on va toujours un
type qui ont costume trois pièces qui
fait président je ne pense pas que quoi
qu est ce qu est ce que ça veut dire
vous savez et si son service public par
exemple on tenait aussi compte de l'avis
du public
ce serait peut-être pas mal vu que ça
s'appelle le service public par exemple
mais d'un autre côté là où il ya ma
limite c'est que je me dis et je le dis
dans le livre on peut pas forcer les
gens
moi j'ai envie du désir des autres c'est
clair qu'est ce qu'on en rit qu'est-ce
qu'on a tous envie ici si on est devant
le public et devant les caméras c'est
qu'on nous aime qu'on nous aime pas ce
qu'on fait et moi j'ai pas du tout envie
d'obliger d'une façon ou d'une autre des
rangs l'auguste personne à dire prends
moi moi je connais pas monsieur tessier
je l' ai vu une fois à priori je suis
pas son genre d'animateurs jeu mais d'un
autre côté je me dis bon c'est le patron
c'est lui qui a les clés mais je
comprends pas pourquoi il ya un tel
acharnement à non non non et non
surtout que je pense qu'après avoir
travaillé longtemps dans le service
commercial avec ce que j'ai fait sur tmc
je suis naturellement conduit à aller
sur le service public
je veux pas retourner à tf1 bon je
trouve quand même que tf1 et sur ce
qu'ils sont c'est une grande chaîne
mais le jour où j'ai eu un pépin
professionnels ils ont changé trottoir
alors si je peux aller ailleurs tant
qu'à faire je préfère aller ailleurs
pourtant il y avait cette émission de la
rédemption sur granville appelez-ça
berio grandeur et décadence d'une star
on peut éviter s'appelle comme ça ça
serait mieux de la plume dans le cul aux
menottes aussi
vous avez une bonne audience malgré un
inédit de colombo en face de vous ce
jour là fine bonnes audiences
et puis non ça va pas l'homme dose on
n'a pas osé
ouais alors ce qui est terrible dans ce
genre de situation parce que je les
connais moi aussi pendant quelques
années c'est que les gens dans la rue
ils vous parlent milliards vous voit
plus à la télé casino fait alors ceux
qui sont à votre place sont pas
terribles alors qu'un mec qui est
chirurgien avocat ou ou menuisier peu
importe qui a perdu son boulot
les gens lui disent pas ça alors les
deux solutions soit se faire refaire le
nom et l'âge soit c'est que gillet mais
tant qu'on est ici c'est haro dans tous
les jours le pire il faut quand même
puisque je profite je fais rarement des
télévisions sur cette chaîne
mais je profite quand même du fait que
quand les journaux annoncent mon retour
dieu sait si on l'annoncé jeudi dans
livre que je n'ai même pas l'aller ce
qui veut dire que jamais je n'ai fait
une déclaration depuis huit ans a besoin
de l'année sur une chaîne jamais mais
faut quand même que je vous dise la
meilleure j'allais assez rapidement en
octobre de gilles quand je mangeais le 7
d'or je ne vais pas recevoir le 7 d'or
pour la bonne raison que la semaine 17
d'or mon père décède dingue je ne vais
pas aller dans ce genre d'endroit et
puis des journaux décide de faire la
couverture avec moi en disant ça y est
c'est le sésame à venir y revenir
eh bien monsieur tessier patron de
france télévisions m'a reproché de
manipuler la presse pour revenir à la
télévision je peux lui dire ce soir que
j'avais autre chose à faire monsieur
tessier que de manipuler la presse vous
éteignez chez vous ici aussi
patrick sabatier imaginez vous ayez en
face de vous patrick le lay et etienne
mougeotte marc tessier pierre lescure
vous leur dites quoi pierre lescure de
toute façon merci puisque je suis sur
une de ces chaînes a été de me jeter à
patrick le lay pourrait mieux faire
aurait pu mieux faire et à marc tessier
[Musique]
et si vous risquez ouais on rallume
djazouli ses fils aime les répétitions
au revoir à bientôt et bientôt que la
prochaine c'est la prochaine pièce
l'école des femmes
l'école des femmes au théâtre de la
commune d'aubervilliers voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
allez perdre ici
l'afrique sabatier comme on l'a dit
c'est un métier où l'on vit du désir des
autres où l'on vit dans le regard des
autres
je vais vous faire une interview miroir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes baffie staff on déboule à
ton copain en israël soit tu vas voir
chez baptiste à fond il va bien c'est
vrai mais oui oui celle de zafy et en
tunisie à la bourre c'est ce qu il ya un
barbare fils qui s'appelle bafiba
baguette bien
alors donc que penseriez-vous patrick
sabatier
si vous étiez vu par votre père par
exemple je pense a plus rien notre mère
il s'est bien occupé de son père votre
frère je peux compter sur lui votre
femme
il pense trop à la télé votre maîtresse
il doit dérange il y en a pas deux
enfants on est aujourd'hui très souvent
victoires une semaine ce qui fait
beaucoup de vos enfants réalisent les
chercher à l'école jeanne à l'école en
dehors du temps libre même à l'époque
vous aviez beaucoup de boulot vous
occupiez beaucoup de nos enfants c'est
vrai notre concierge bas que je n'oublie
pas aux étrennes
voilà le percepteur que je n'oublie pas
non plus votre patron que je dois être
très exigeant un peu trop un
ouais et votre ancien patron le lait je
pense que ce que le même reproche c'est
d'avoir gagner trop d'argent sur tf1
ouais et bénévoles
si vous étiez vu par le regard de votre
réalisateur diriez quoi
le temps n'efface pas tout votre
coiffeur
il n'est pas toujours bien coiffée ça va
pas toujours votre maquillage
ils me demandent plus de travail
qu'avant il ya une couche aussi votre
médecin
il vient me voir pas assez souvent notre
psy mais pas de problème peut-être votre
meilleur ami d'ami et plus d'argent si
je suis je crois on peut compter sur lui
ouais ouais et votre pire ennemi
on peut compter sur lui
et
vous sentez amoral théâtre voulons pas
de travail et monsieur eh oui monsieur
répète alors on navigue messieurs
[Applaudissements]
et
laver
j'accueille elie semoun
m
public 1 c'est un vrai public de
télévision ouais c'est un vrai public de
télévision regarde
voilà tu pousses assez ténue
l'incertitude du 21 novembre 31 décembre
vous êtes au bataclan vous donnais 20
représentations exceptionnelles de votre
nouveau spectacle mis en scène par roger
louret way des baladins de l'agenais
ouais c'était mon premier patron
j'étais petit c'est de la même famille
que muriel robin voilà c'est tout sarlat
texte de vous et de franck dubosc exact
qui officie tous les jours à 19h sur
france 2 dans on a tout essayé avec
henri kg et donc vous savez comment on
fait pour votre spectacle
oui je sais mais je vais pas le faire
pourquoi parce que la dernière fois que
je suis venu j'avais fondé une
association de loi 1901
parce que je trouve ça ridicule d'agiter
les mains j'ai déposé mes statuts mais
pas longtemps et je suis en passe de te
faire un procès qui nous ont aussi
j'ai engagé des poursuites judiciaires
je refuse de d'agiter main comme un
crétin c'est que c'est une insulte pour
les sourds-muets insulte pour le public
je le sais sûr mais aussi l'appeler
lancement chez les sourds muets public
le fait c'est l'essentiel
bien alors on envoyer tout le monde en
parle a envoyé une caméra parce que le
spectacle n'existe pas évidemment enfin
il n'a pas commencé du personne ne l'a
vu personne non je vais passer ça j'ai
fait j'ai une bonne excuse donc on a
envoyé une caméra oui mais à temps il
faut que j'explique quand même plus le
mec est venu me filmer ses amis dit oui
mais j'étais en répétition n'y a
absolument aucun rire ya rien n'y avait
personne dans la salle et je me suis dit
que c'était ça pouvait être sympa de
montrer un petit extrait mal et auxerre
c'est pour moi un moment tu raccroches
s'il te plaît c'est bon c'est pour moi
ma main ouais je vais le faire mais
continue pas à crier parce que si jamais
tu continues à crier après je ne ferai
pas presse a bien côtoient cache
vraiment oui kevin hin c'était ma mère
elle veut toujours que je range ma
chambre
elle est trop hystérique en plus se
disant que je passe des heures au
téléphone n'importe quoi non il a
toujours pas appelé je suis très
amoureuse non avec abdelatif cfi qui
braque les hommes je préfère quand il
sent plus mûr à 14 ans et des vrais
bébés alors que julien il a déjà une
mobylette et une petite moustache en
plus nadia m'a dit qu'il a sûrement déjà
fait l'amour qu'on remarque c'est normal
il a quand même 14 ans et demi tu as vu
ce matin dans la cour il a cassé la
bandoulière son sac à dos a été
commandée riom en plus en cours
d'anglais l'arrêté palma tms en peluche
et belle famille de suite à gauche tu es
trop gêné à tanger un double appel c'est
peut-être lui alloue asie toi papa
ouais tu veux rentrer plus tard que
prévu tu as une réunion au quai jules
dire à maman kevin ah ouais c'était mon
père il est chez sa maîtresse
qu'est ce qu'en disaient ouais julien
trop mignon j'ai grave les boules
ce matin il parlait à nadia et tu sais
quoi
yb en des ouais c'est elle qui me l'a
dit je serai bien voulu être là j'arrête
pas dit pincer chez trois amoureux j'ai
jamais été amoureuse aussi longtemps
trois jours je m'en fous s'il veut pas
sortir avec moi je me suicide ou alors
je sors avec kader quand il retrouve
kader way sans ses boutons il serait
trop bien 30 quand j'ai déjà en train de
trophées julien 21 novembre et 1er
décembre 20 représentations
exceptionnelles
il ya une tournée avant je vais je vais
me balader un peu et puis après je vais
faire une retournée puis au mois de mai
je vais être à l'olympia bon bah
dépêchez vous parce que le vin
représentation il faut aller il faut les
réserver tout de suite vous verrez un
mois chez les places tout de suite oui
tout de suite dit le bas oui tout de
suite mais c'est horrible de devenir
faire la promotion d'un spectacle qui
est bien ouais mais on en parle toujours
mal tu vois ce que je dirai combien pour
voilà non mais je suis jeune je ne sais
pas je sais du 21 novembre au 31
décembre
et c'est un nouveau spectacle et on a on
a écrit
non mais je suis pas un marchand de
tapis j'y arrive pas
les nuits vous êtes prêts oui on va
faire une interview sans intérêt dans la
bouche mais on ne bouge pas pendant le
qinghai
[Musique]
génial dès que ma fille est partie il ya
quand même beaucoup moins deux d'affilée
shirel 10 mois et a rappelé la meuf là
non ah bon
sa part appelé non non je comprends pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi hop parce que je
n'ai pas fidèlement numéro un
peut-être du coup on a parfois ouais
c'était là la mer ou à la montagne pas
hésité à la mer mais ouais c'était
moyennement d'autres d'un trop de chance
sur le trop de sable trop de trop de
j'aime pas bien faire
ouais ouais t'as pas fait pas dix balles
pour le cas dit il
non je fais rentrer du fioul ouais j'ai
fait rentrer du chemin alors il y en a
suffisamment pour le mois de décembre
est le moment que pour janvier
normalement on est sur le coup peut-être
y avait aussi un cousin qui va passer
pour aller voler ça va je fais tout le
monde en parle la voiture allait fermer
la tête à penser de fermeture non
justement j'ai mon arme qui marchent
plus
je ne vais pas aller où je me suis foutu
au parquet à moi ça va alors il ya un
gardien ça va toi sinon ça va
ouais ça va je fais tout le monde en
parle oui oui ça va t'as pas vu ma
personne non je la trouve plus ça se
passe bien toi ouais c'est vrai tu fais
quoi en ce moment tout le monde en parle
a ouais d'accord mais tu crois
structures n'ont pas trop et c'est pas
ses parents comme il ya quelque chose
qui me dérange d'un truc je fais plus en
parler
[Applaudissements]
je me suis toujours demandé si tu aimes
et des chiens moi je me suis posé la
même question hier et puis j'ai glissé
sur un truc et puis je me suis dit que
j'aimais pas les chiens ça va tu as et
je passe bien je suis toujours dans
parle bien sûr que tu en penses que ça
s'organise bien des chemises naturel où
j'ai acheté chez jeunesse pij et
chemisier chemisier ben je me suis dit
que bon il fallait un petit peu ça va je
me sens un petit peu crispé tu vois mais
ça ira mieux bien pâle chossat a pas
trop gras trop chaud en même temps il
fait chaud ici
ouais ça m'étonnait la chemise de seine
ouais ça se passe bien je fais tout le
monde en parle moi ça s'organise
c'est vrai ça va ça tombe bien méchant
qui met un climat qui n'est pas
longtemps pour les questions
non mais c'est pas pour les fêtes tu
fais quoi alors pour les fêtes par
exemple noël ouais et je vais
probablement acheté à sa fin
eh ben
le
j'accueille maintenant jean glavany
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes habillé en
tricolore là j'ai pas fait exprès à la
france est en guerre il se dit il faut
être un peu cocardier 1
je le suis un peu oui ouais bien alors
vous êtes ancien chef de cabinet de
françois mitterrand aujourd'hui ministre
de l'agriculture et de la pêche
satan
je sais c'est qu'on s'accorde un
ministre je sais si c'est elle alors
vous êtes déjà venu ici vous allez
raconter votre vie la prostitution là à
mon avis vous confondez chaque fois en
même ça sur le tapis bon c'est une
boulette vous étiez jeune voilà c'était
il ya des erreurs de jeunesse comme ça
notamment de votre part voilà donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes ici parce que vous
publiez un livre chez grasset qui
s'appelle c'est comment on fait c'est
notre politique folle
même pour un socialiste même pour un
social et j'aime les socialistes mais je
refuse cette association a drainé donc
lé socialiste que tu préfères oui
d'adressé mon ami je te donne une chance
de se rendre à nice n'est pas encore mon
ami et pourtant comme chez un bon ami
delanoë dans le fait juste une parce
qu'on est moitié amis alors valises
j'ai longtemps je vais me faire
engueuler parce qu'on est une
association oui je sais de l'association
louis ferran guerre qu'ils font pas les
mains oui y avait déjà les bassistes
comme les sectionnistes comment ça
s'appelle ton addiction c'est une
association mais ses mots ni féministe
ouais anti m'a gentiment
c'est horrible bien tient quelques
harvey sonia levons le ps envoyez-moi
des emails ça me fera du bien jean
glavany
merci de réserver votre première
télévision à tout le monde en parle
ça me fait plaisir je vous alors pour
rendre votre livre plus accessible pour
le public qui nous regardent
j'ai décidé de faire pendant on a écrit
en français mais aussi en français alors
si je vous faire une interview vous ou
donc on va rentrer et on va faire de la
pipolisation on va rentrer par les noms
des gens dont vous parlez ce qui sera
plus simple on va commencer avec
l'opposition
douste-blazy mais vous dites c'est un
enfant gâté il n'a jamais perdu des
élections
il promet des choses mirobolantes des
choses irréalisables par exemple une
écurie de formule 1 à lourdes c'est vrai
bon c'est bizarre où les jeux olympiques
d'hiver dans les pyrénées oui je les
gelées bien connu puisque on a été un
on a eu un conte par courtrai parallèle
est très proche puisque on est élu dans
deux circonscriptions voisines on est
élu maire ensemble pour la première en
89 lui dans à lourdes la cité marc est
allé moi dans un petit village s'appelle
maubourguet était encore amoureux
[Musique]
mais c'est le premier des choses
mirobolants déchets c1 c'est un type
formidable qu'il ya une capacité de
promettre tout et n'importe quoi
évidemment ne s'est jamais tenir ses
promesses parce que c'est bien on sait
pas tenable donc il n'a pas encore
appris qu'en politique il fallait tout
faire très peu très peu de promesses
voire même pas du tout quoi simplon la
promesse de faire son possible on fait
des conneries à toulouse la suit pas ce
qu'il a fait il aurait pas dû fumer
lorsque tu sais il a fait une connerie
jusqu'à drôle ça ah bon ça c'est ma
fille c'est pas moi c'est ma fille qui
est dans mon cas est rentré dans la
tuerie beaucoup commenté book laurent
située dans mon corps sort tout de suite
séduit 1 qu'il dit ça c'est pas moi sur
le banc faire [ __ ]
or est laurent merde c'est chiant il est
vulgaire faire sortir le bac fille qui
est en vous oui on est tonnes hier matin
à les faire sortir celle ci fait sortir
se situer en moi
elle est allée de la sortir il doit
sortir
il doit sortir le 9 il veut sortir ça y
est ça y est
ouais le défi qui était en lui est sorti
j'avais lu bien alors vous devez vous
sentir mieux on sent mieux là c'était
terrible c'est un trush je me sentais
encore voilà et dans ma tête il ya les
beats 5
ça va mieux
ah oui sur exemple je vous dit [ __ ]
c'est dingue on est mieux là d'un coup
jean louis debré alors là vous l'accusez
carrément d'être l'organisateur de la
réunion de nationalistes corses à trélon
cas d'accord les mecs et les cagoules là
vous dites que c'est un défi à l'état de
droit et c'est vrai que la part d'un
ministre
ça vous choque un petit peu oui je fonce
les faits sont avérés maintenant tout
cas moi je quand j'avais enquêter en
corse à la tête d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire
on avait découvert ce truc ahurissant
quoi et je trouve qu'un ministre de
l'intérieur qui demande à 600 type en
armes de se réunir avec des cagoules et
des mitrailleuses et mitraillettes pour
faire une démonstration de force dans
une espèce de mise en scène qui devait
correspondre à une pensée politique
genre si vous êtes nombreux
on va vous croirez si vous déclarez en
plus que vous allez faire la paix ça
sera un bon mais évidemment ils n'ont
pas déclaré qu'il a fait et je trouve
que mise à l'intérieur qui provoque une
manifestation armée je trouve ça en
droit à uris temps c'est vrai que c'est
faux et celui-ci est fou et en même
temps c'est qu'au fond tout le monde le
sait depuis ça c'était il ya déjà
quelques années quoi et puis c'est
impuni la démocratie suit son cours et
monsieur debré qui a fait ça est impuni
donc voila moi je dis mon étonnement que
ce genre de chose restent impunis ouais
bah oui si c'est vrai c'est incroyable
ah mais c'est vrai alors dites-moi ce
gamin je voulais rencontrer dans les
tribunes du stade vélodrome va
rencontrer souvent dans des stades de
sport parce qu'il est passionné de sport
de foot en particulier quand il était
jeune énarque il a écrit un rapport sur
le financement du foot qui peut
inquiéter attraits de 20 à quoi ils
avaient bien deviner quand les choses
allaient évoluer et un jour
effectivement je raconte c'était le
match d'ouverture de la coupe du monde
de football à marseille france afrique
du sud juste à côté billets et puis je
sais pas pourquoi il s'est livré à moi
une manière qui était assez ahurissante
quoi et pourrait présent république faut
avoir un parti il faut avoir un appareil
10 ans et vous aviez ouais mais tant
qu'il ya ce type alors vous dites mais
qui sait ce type puis d'un mouvement du
menton comme ça il a désigné de chirac
j'aime bien tous les deux j'ai pas
l'impression justement c'est un peu ce
que j'ai voulu dire
alors vous n'êtes pas tendre non plus
avec jacques chirac le présent la
république vous parler ses billets
d'avion en liquide
gvt a laissé passer six ans je me
souviens simplement que que que
bérégovoy
il s'est suicidé dans leur propre public
pour un prêt d'un million de francs et
et puis on a d'autres il paye deux
millions et demi un millier d'avions en
est qui les puits puis petit on trouve
ça peut enfin non j'espère que l'on
trouve pas ça normal donc voilà c'est
dit des choses comme ça parce que je les
ai vécus spontanément je te connais un
autre de mes amis qui s'appelle
emmanuelli dont pourtant les juges ont
reconnu qu'ils ne s'était pas enrichi
d'enrichissement personnel
mais qui parce qu'il avait été trésorier
du ps a pris deux ans de suspension de
prat civique bon mais je pense à ses
amis là bas parce que parce que ils ont
payé non de sa vie est bon voilà c'est
pas très drôle mais j'ai aimé ce que
j'ai dit ces choses là a choisi de ses
co ce que vous dites c'est qu'au ps
c'est plûtot les commissions sur les
marchés alors que c'était toi les
valises de billets oui ce que je dis
jamais partie de sa culture en même
temps oui mais c'est qu'il semble dire
au delà
l'anti c'était c'était comme ça dans le
ton j'espère que c'est plus comme ça du
tout mais je vous en ai dessus espère
tous oui et donc oui il y avait deux
cultures il y avait une culture de
gauche ou au fond on se débrouillait à
coups de fausses factures c'est une
sorte de notoriété publique c'est à dire
que quand on faisait dans les
collectivités locales des marchés
publics ont ajouté une commission de
val-alain 2,3 je sais pas 2%
et pourquoi on faisait ça parce qu'on
voulait pas que les élus s'enrichissent
voilà et donc on faisait ça pour
centraliser les choses c'est à l'usure
du ps et des voleurs c'est sur les
autres c'était la culture du vous avez
un marché vous nous aviez dit il faut
dire à nos amis ça on voulait qu'ils
sachent c'est qu'à l'époque il avait le
choix donc entre ce qu'avait le pognon
dans des valises et ce qui faisait des
fausses factures
c'est un choix politique afin de dire
les choses comme ça parce que c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé et répandant
des recettes et des voleurs malhonnêtes
des gens se débrouillaient d'une manière
par l'ombre ou quoi faut reconnaître les
choses et et d'un côté on voulait pas
s'enrichir mais on faisait des trucs on
ne l'est pas que les élus s'enrichissent
morose et des trucs qui étaient visibles
quoi deux jours on a vu une fausse
facture on a tout compris et puis tout
le système est parti et il y en a qui
sont passés de procès en procès et
l'autre système et ils étaient
invérifiables imprenable tout le monde
sait qu'il existait tout le monde sait
mais je raconte ça d'une manière qu'on
me dira détailler les valises de billets
circulaient sinon c'est invérifiable et
ça a probablement permis d
enrichissement personnel loire vous
parlez aussi des fonds spéciaux à vous
vous regrettez finalement que jacques
chirac soit parti de matignon avec des
fonds spéciaux qu'il a apporté à la
mairie de paris et ben là aussi vous
dites c'est relativement impunis tous ne
le sait mais personne ça même été dit
par un de ses conseillers qui a dit qu'à
raconter comment il était parti avec
urique way pour le puisque vous le citez
1 qui était partie avec les fonds
spécial et de laisser le solde des fonds
spéciaux pratiques non de matignon pour
le mettre dans le coffre de la mairie de
paris
c'est de l'argent public et ça aussi
c'est bon c'est ça parce que j'espère
que les gens s'en souviennent et puis en
tirons des leçons apparemment les gens
ils en tiennent pas trop rigueur aux
hommes politiques qui font ça finalement
c'est là la conclusion que l'on peut
partir dans quelques mois ouais ouais
voilà ben on l'a vu on a vu l'opposition
passe à la majorité
chevènement ouais c'est un processus de
matignon son départ du gouvernement
la chevènement c'est quelqu'un pour qui
j'ai beaucoup de respect d'amitié et
d'estimé
c'est un homme d'état quand il parle
politique c'est quelqu'un qui élèvent
toujours le débat qui ne rabaisse pas
sauf que je pense que chevènement a fait
une erreur majeure d'appréciation c'est
que il ya une affaire vous avez sans
doute entendu parler qui s'appelle la
sphère des paillotes une des gendarmes
et un préfet ont été accusés de mettre
le feu volontairement des paillotes et
donc l'état était démuni pouvait plus
rien faire et moi je pense qu' il
fallait pas sous-estimer ce avec le
processus de matignon a été une
initiative prise par jospin pour
redonner la main à l'état pour remettre
la lah les relations entre la corse et
la république sur une dynamique
constructive avant ce n'est plus
possible
c'est ce que raconte le préfet bonnet
parce que vous êtes en train de me
raconter quand mais je le connais bien
préfet bonnet chez j'ai lu ici vous en
parler c'est pas du tout sa version ré
mais moi je peux raconter beaucoup de
choses sous préfet dé monsieur les jeux
les jeux les connu je les encourage et
dans sa mission au début et puis je
pense que il a failli dans sa tâche mais
claude allègre c'est pas votre copain
vous dit comment jospin at il pu tolérer
un mec pareil dans son entourage et au
gouvernement
c'est une énigme il n'est pas comme nous
toutes façons il est prévu claude
allaire c1 c'est un exemple formidable
dans la vie politique de quelqu'un qui a
raison sur le fond tout ce qu'il disait
sur l'éducation nationale était juste
toutes les réformes qu'il a proposé
était pertinente et qui sait impuissante
et tout seul par son comportement parce
qu'il disait pas bonjour parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas polis parce qu'il ne
faisait pas quand ils étaient en retard
ou quoi dans la vie politique
voilà le comportement ça compte aussi
ouais et être disponible vis-à-vis des
des gens de ses électeurs des élus de et
je pense effectivement que finalement la
faiblesse d'alex et qu'il n'était pas
élu parce que je pense qu'un élu qui va
dans sa circonscription et puis il doit
se coltiner ses électeurs il aurait
engueulé 1,6 s'était comporté comme ça
avec plusieurs règles simples être poli
ne pas les volets way ne pas alors de
faire de fausses promesses
on apprend la rendre des comptes à
rendre des comptes a menti pas mentir et
je pense que la vie politique a exacerbé
comme ça c'est en train d'un politique
je trouvais la vie politique française
pour une chatte rue qu'elle évolue bien
dans ce sens là bas mais c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est la vie
politique vu par un ministre qui dit les
choses quoi j'essaye way la prêche fait
de la paix celle ans sans décote
moi je m'occupe de la pêche en mer tous
cas eric l'hameçon les la mouche à tout
ça c'est pourri c'est intéressant
alors lui il est branché par les plantes
tu fais pousser du cannabis et non je
fais pas poussé le cannabis j'aime la
plante tropicale mais avant c'est une
plante tropicale
bah je vais en faire pousser
parlant de l'émission poser la question
sur le cabanier une anecdote mon petit
mon petit village des hautes pyrénées
dont j'étais maire mais quand on devient
ministre ce point vaut plus qu'on soit
mer c'est bien et on tombe je sais ça je
le regrette beaucoup à joe il ya une
enquête de gendarmerie qui enquêtait sur
un trafic d'autoradio ils rendent chez
un un suspect kt et puis trouve pas
d'autoradio mais il trouve sur sa table
de nuit quelques quelques feuilles de
cannabis 1 etc des gendarmes se lever et
ça vient de chez mon cousin commence à
votre cousin et un tel mec se
précipitent chez le cousin en plein dans
le village et ils fouillent la maison et
trouve au grenier des milliers de
feuilles de cannabis qui s'était en
train de sécher c ou d
lester ya deux ou trois ans et dix mille
d'où ça vient ça et le type les regarder
dujardin et découvre dans le jardin 500
pieds de cannabis en plein village ont
tout brûlé évidemment ils ont tout brûlé
parce que c'est illégal la culture du
cannabis il faut bien que de temps en
temps les gendarmes fassent quand même
c'est pas comme ailleurs c'est ce que je
veux dire et donc
et donc voilà c'est une histoire vraie
hrw a léché plein maubourguet 500
pompiers gros comme ça on continue
pierre bérégovoy alors donc justement
pierre bérégovoy vous parlez de ça au
sujet de la drogue du pouvoir c'est à
dire le vide qu'on ressent quand on perd
le pouvoir et vous avez une expérience
la dépression de l'ancien ministre je
vois des hommes ou des femmes politiques
je vais reconnaître à droite comme à
gauche de ses partisans qu ont un besoin
d'exercer le pouvoir qui presque maladif
est vrai que comme quand ils sont pas
dans le pouvoir que dans une position ne
pense qu'à ça avoir un pouvoir une part
de thouars et quand ils sont dans
pouvoir ils n'ont qu'une peur c'est de
le perdre si bien quand ils perdent ils
ne cessent de drogue pour vous voyez
l'exercice du pouvoir
et quand ils le perdent subi et anne
donc ouais et est tellement qui est
déprimant je les ai vus chez plusieurs
hommes politiques à droite comme à
gauche mais de manière très fin mais je
crois qu'il faut vraiment garder
beaucoup de disques en menant à pour
pouvoir et se dire plus intrigant votre
bouquin à patrick
metallerie dans votre bouquin dit ce qui
vous manque le plus
plus que signer des autographes la
célébrité tout parce que vous êtes
toujours très célèbre et rémy cote de
notoriété qui est assez inchangé malgré
ces longues années
mais c'est vrai vous dites ce qui me
manque le plus c'est ma drogue si la
préparation des émissions ah oui bien
sûr je comprends très bien ce que des
gens qu à venir pour l'exercice du
pouvoir c'était qu'à un moment donné on
est dans une situation où il n'y a pas
de grands politique c'est aussi vrai
pour les artistes c'est vrai par les
voilà pour les sportifs et voilà c'est à
dire qu'on a envie d'un on a envie de
quelque chose je parle il n'y a pas de
retraite là ya pas de sakarya rien on a
envie d'être de d'employés en même temps
ça qu'un de nous amener les uns les
autres journalistes artistes sportifs
hommes politiques à garder une petite
distance par rapport à tout ça parce que
je sais pas quand on perd le pouvoir ou
une émission meurt pas moi je sais que
si demain je suis plus miss je serais
très heureux ouais autrement autrement
qu'en pousser mes amis ça que c'est
gbagbo c'est que je ferai
vous avez déjà pu mais il ya très
longtemps
non j'ai pas dit ça sert écoutez j'ai
été étudiant en 68 à nanterre vous
imaginez que bon oui mais mais je me
sentais dans 68 à nanterre où l année
suivante mais mais mais c'est mieux
c'est tout danger pour jospin il
légalise pas la marijuana mais c'est
bien parce que c'est une question qui
est pas simple ah ben moi dans ma tête
le débat ils partagent en deux quoi jeu
parce que on à partir du moment où je
génère a raison de dire s'ils tentent %
de nos enfants fument les enfants de
jospin et martine aubry
soixante six ans c'est rien
si 60% de nos enfants fument des pétards
c'est évident que ce sont pas des
délinquants 60% de nos enfants sont pas
des délinquants donc je me pose cette
question
et puis d'autre d'une autre côté de ma
tête je me dis mais mais si on est petit
on égalise à après on va les gagner quoi
ces mêmes gens se dirigent encore pire
et bien entendu faut poser c'est pas les
l'abus d'alcool
parler de ça voilà en tout et applaudi a
pas d'interdît du débat il faut que les
jeunes mais les parents aussi les puits
les médecins que ce débat public ait
lieu et que société comme la nôtre soit
assez mature pour pouvoir se poser ce
genre de problème sans que cela soit un
tabou un parlons-en aux états unis à 21
ans pas à boire voilà ça et sont tous là
14 15 16 chalets non j'ai passé du
champagne s'est passé mais c'est
hypocrite c'est un peu plus voilà et de
lamentable
bienvenue
à l'influencé qu'ils s'appellent gail
lewis magail
mais j'ai haï y guénard
[Musique]
il savait qu'elle me fait il s'appelle
gaia bellugi voilà après tout série
dinnigan idc gagne c'est tout il va être
content ce soir si serrée après on va
continuer on continue françois
mitterrand alors vous l'accusez un petit
peu d'être responsable du désamour pour
les politiques vous citer cette phrase
terrible de mitterrand le chômage mais
que voulez vous y faire
il continue alors que nous avons tout
fait pour l'endiguer il y avait une
résignation devant une sorte de fatalité
du chômage qui était pour moi la
négation du volontarisme
je pense qu'on n'avait pas tous fait la
preuve depuis un an après ça ça a
commencé de marché même s'il faut être
très prudent et vous a déçu ce jour là
oui mais bon globalement il m'a pas déçu
non vie ce jour là oui c'est ça vous
avez déçu alors j'ose pas alors je n'ose
pas vous dites il est formidable parce
que tous les ministres peuvent parler
dans les conseils des ministres a pas de
problème avec ses bras tous les
ministres peuvent parler de tous les
ministères ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant vous dites que grâce à jospin
c'est possible
et alors sur le trotskisme vous dit
c'est pas grave allait qui les titres ce
qui est assez fou qu'on sait plus tôt
c'est vrai non mais attendez je le dis
oui je m'en fous moi même si je pense
que 99 9% des français c'est pourquoi je
veux dire pourquoi moi c'est parce que
les gens ont leur a expliqué depuis des
années que le méchant c'était staline le
méchant c'était lénine etc trotskiste un
mec vachement sympa en fait ce qui il a
fait fusiller les marranes cronstadt et
l'a ouvert les premiers camps
d'extermination en urss s'avance à pas
non moi je vous dis moi je dis que trop
dit c'était une révolte contre le
stalinisme et contre le un régime
totalitaire le régime du goulag
en urss donc dans l'histoire des idées
politiques en france au trotskysme
d'abord et surtout été vécu comme ça oui
enfin trotsky le personnage trotsky été
viré par sa ligne s'il était resté il
aurait été aussi méchant que les autres
puisqu'il ya deux semaines il était
trotskiste dans les années 60 70 avant
d'être au ps honnêtement là aussi je moi
je me souviens nanterre 68 69
il fut si ce qui est épatant trotskiste
aux gauchistes moi tous mes copains
l'était je sais pas comment j'y suis pas
arrivé moi ça me choque pas non moi je
trouve ça comme dit mon ami jean
c'est là
plutôt sympa mouais et puis tout le
monde s'en fout c'est parce que la
question de l'entrisme alors oublions le
trotskiste quand un type vous à l'époque
vous connaissiez je sais pas vous
bossiez avec lui vous le voyez tous les
jours ils vous disaient pas qu'il était
trotskiste il nous a menti mais non mais
il était quand il rentre au parti
socialiste il s'inscrit dans la logique
du parti ce site appelé tous est resté
jusqu'en 82 ou 83 je sais ce que vous
dites et saab sera contre certains mais
moi ce que je dis askolovitch un couac
ont passé du temps à dix après ça comme
ça parce que ce serait très imprudent de
leur part de 10 à il dira qu ils disent
qu'ils auraient eu des conversations
après à être entré au parti avec eux et
avec des trous ce qui se passe
moi j'ai des conversations avec des gens
qui pensent pas comme moi et même prix
quand j'ai changé
ben oui ce que je veux dire je vais vous
poser une seule question les socialistes
au ps vous savez pas que mitterrand a vu
la france si vous saviez pas que c'est
qu'il avait une fille qui s'appelait
mazarine
vous saviez pas que jospin était
trotskiste vous saviez quoi vous savez
tout ça c'est son prénom mais bien sûr
mais lis tout ce que vous saviez pas que
il été trotskiste non ça je l'aï
découvert il ya quelques mois c'est j'ai
vu le bouquin je vois bien que courageux
alors
politique
messieurs
alors jean moulin amis vous savez que
cinq minutes c'est savoir gérer des
catastrophes vous n'avez jamais beaucoup
la vache folle l'erika et cetera
donc on va vous faire une interview
catastrophe on ne bouge pas pendant
qu'on ne bouge pas on ne bouge pas
pendant l'e3 la bouche on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
il ya un nid de baffes islam et bien il
vous demande de le cacher pour une nuit
vous faites quoi
je le fais pas pour jouer à tanger le
sens ayant dit ça je suis troublé parce
que l'écologie est un sens maladive de
l'amitié mais je pense que je le garde
évidemment j'ai tous ses copains jusqu'à
34 yeux quand même boulot de jus parle
d'abord avant de me juger par l'avant
mais ouais mais vous êtes du mal à
cacher théorie s'il a tué quand même
votre fils a volé chez vous un tableau
votre tableau préféré pour s'acheter de
la cam vous fait quoi si une catastrophe
charade tout j'arrête la politique et je
m'occupe de lui
ah ouais ouais vous dit s'il en est
arrivé là c'est que je m'en occupe pas
assez de vivre est comme celle d'autres
qui disent faciles d'autres qui se
défoncent avec la cam du fils boudant
pas du tout pendant les vacances d'été
en famille
ne tombons pas pas vous retrouver salle
un jour comme ça dans la maison avec
votre belle mère et votre belle-mère fou
vous fait des avances faites quoi
à saint-gilles l'esprit gens bien sûr
impossible mais impossible de pour
impossible impossible
enfin impossible que je réponde à ces
avancées impossible non impossible
ouais je suis incapable ouais si moche
que ça
[Applaudissements]
vous draguer une fille sublime vous la
ramenez chez vous un peu comme dans ce
joyeux ce pack la pièce d'arditi et
votre femme est pas là vous découvrez
que c'est un travelo fait quoi mais je
fais quoi machine arrière deux filles
vous annonce qu'elle va se marier
il s'appelle omar ben laden vous faites
quoi je parle à ma fille alors vous êtes
contrôlés pendant le week-end sur une
route avait dans une voiture sympa je
vais pas la safrane d'être comme ça avec
votre voiture
voilà les gendarmes vous contrôler il
inspecte la voiture et à ce moment là
votre pote votre votre ami qu à côté de
vous vous avoue qu'il transporte un kilo
de cocaïne fait quoi quel con une
catastrophe c'est pas vrai un cdd non
merde il est où la vache folle qui avait
gagné deux vies crois que je lèverai bon
l'argent qu'est ce qu'on fait est que
cette coquille ouvrage la brûlure jeu
alors je la jette dans le caniveau
c'est con le jour même du mariage de
votre fille vous tombez amoureux de son
fiancé omar ben laden fait quoi
en fait deux malheureux pourquoi deux à
votre fille d'abord parce qu'elle pourra
pas l'épousé puis omar parce que vous
aimez pas lui dire son nom me sens ça
peut changer à thoune a je sais comme je
suis je sais pas comment je serai dans
10 ou 20 ans
[Applaudissements]
alors samedi dernier à la 68e minute du
match france algérie
quelques dizaines de jeunes ont trompé
la vigilance des policiers des stadiers
et ont envahi le terrain
larbitre a aussitôt décidé d'arrêter le
match à ce moment là dans le poste j'ai
vu djamel bouras qui assistait au match
je vais proposer de venir en parler avec
nous ce soir
il a accepté il à merci voici djamel
bouras
bonsoir alors donc vous étiez au stade
vous expliquer comment ça s'est passé
tout le monde s'explique dans ça a
commencé par des sifflements lors de la
marseillaise comment ça s'est passé
écoutez ça a commencé au début c'était
sympa ouais et après c'est parce qu'il
s'est passé mais moi j'ai pas compris
ils ont sifflé damas à de la
marseillaise donc j'ai pas trouvé ça
terrible du tout j'étais même choqué
j'avais pas les mots sur place en fin
j'étais vraiment je m'attendais pas du
tout à ça j'attendais un match de de
paix un peu de tolérance de mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une chose c'est qu'on peut
pas régler l'histoire avec un match de
foot qui dure 90 minutes et on a
tellement mis de pression là-dessus que
mais bon c'est pas pour ça et ce ne sont
pas excusables du tourin sur ce je
trouve sa demie cible que dès que des
français citent la marseillaise ou
n'importe quel film mais les jeunes qui
sont descendus sur le terrain ils sont
français
oui c'est le français pourquoi ils
descendent avec un drapeau algérien ben
savez quand c'est pour ça que je vais
vous répondre sur le parcours que j'ai
fait j'ai écrit ça dans mon livre c'est
que toute mon enfance mes parents quand
ils sont venus ici c'était un passage
pour eux s'étaient pas éternelle pour
tout le temps dans ce passage c'était
pas chez eux ici donc dans l'éducation
on m'a éduqué en me disant g l un
algérien n'est pas français toute ma vie
ça a été ça enfin jusqu'à 16 ans 1 est
juste déclic lorsque j'ai eu la chance
je dis bien j'ai eu la chance de monter
à paris parce que je suis originaire de
lyon dans les quartiers où on nous a mis
entre nous on va dire qu'entre français
d'origine étrangère et c'est quand j'ai
eu la chance de monter à 16 ans je me
suis dit j'ai eu c'est là où j'ai
compris qu'en fait que je devais être
français que je devais fier d'être
français et parce que j'ai ramené
énormément médaille pour la france et
que j'étais faire de ce pays
et puis voilà ces jeunes qui sont venus
sur le terrain samedi qui
sifflé lamarthe est marseillaise et moi
aussi je comme djamel bouras je montre
c'est regrettable et choquant bien des
égards en même temps je suis sûr que
beaucoup d'entre eux sont les mêmes qui
a deux ou trois ans défilé des drapeaux
français
je vous donnais applaudissez zidane
champion du monde et cette france black
blanc beur qui avait gagné mais c'est
tout c'est bon là qui font mal alors là
c'est tous ces mots là pendant toute mon
excusez-moi de vous couper un don mais
lorsque quand j'ai réussi je me suis dit
ça y est je ramène des jetés dans le
monde entier avec le drapeau français
bénéteau j'étais fier j'avais les larmes
aux yeux
soit j'étais vraiment content et quand
je revenais avec ma médaille alors en
tant que bear comment ça va des français
qu'est ce que c'est c'est mon l'abord je
ne connais pas moi je connais de bord
que je mets matin ce sont mes tartines
que ce bord là je veux que je ne
comprends pas alors est ce que vous
sentez bien intégré je fais intégration
de quoi c'est moi je défends les valeurs
républicaines
je suis fière de ses valeurs je suis un
français comme vous c'est quoi tout de
suite on nous a mis à l'écart on nous a
exclus
mais le problème c'est que on ne va pas
chercher quand l'italien si le français
d'origine italienne où le français
d'origine polonaise de n'importe quel
autre origine cantillation soissons ces
pays d'origine qui vont gilet pour
l'italie c'est un fall ces gens là c'est
pareil ils étaient là pour l'algérie
mais quand la france a gagné j'étais ils
ont fait là c'est vrai j'ai parlé avec
des jeunes qui étaient là bas parce que
j'étais fou de rage quand je suis sorti
gsm m2 enfin deux d'intervenir
et quand j'ai parlé avec les mandibules
tu sais déjà mais on n'a pas s'ils n'en
sont fous de la mercedes du salon a
signé on a on a sifflé par dont on a
sifflé la marseillaise c'est parce que
c'était david et goliath et nous on
était pour david tu devrais donc c'est
un peu ça quoi c'est quoi ce que dans
ces histoires là on est toujours obligé
de s'expliquer à cause d'une centaine de
crétins r je ne pense pas que la
majorité des gens qui étaient là bas on
siffler la marseillaise
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont rentrés
dans le stade et c'est tout c'est ça
c'est pareil pour les
et ce qui se passe en banlieue c'est dix
mecs 20 mecs les terroristes c'est quoi
ces 125 100 mecs dans le monde et dans
le monde
on est obligé de changer notre vie de de
changer notre façon de penser à cause de
ces [ __ ] magie c'est important parce
que la plus tarder et en plus c'est mal
tombée puisque c'est un contexte
horrible en ce moment donc il ya des
gens qui font l'amalgamé entre arabes et
juristes et musulmans c'est mais de la
part de ces mecs là qui sont rentrés sur
le stade c'est devrait comprendre il
devra ceci étant quand même on a vu
lundi dernier sur france 2 dans
l'émission mots croisés dans les deux
chabot on a vu des jeunes dire très
simplement d'ailleurs ok on nous demande
de faire trois minutes de silence pour
le world trade center
mais pourquoi on fait pas trois minutes
de silence pour les milliers de morts
qui sont dus à l'embargo de l'irak au
bombardement de l'irak
j'ai pas vu beaucoup jusqu'à maintenant
de deux jeunes d'origine maghrébine
être fondamentalement du côté des
américains ils disent oui c'est vrai
c'est terrible ce qui s'est passé au
world trade center
mais malgré tout nous aussi il ya la
palestine ya l'irak
je suis contre tout tout terroriste mais
je trouve que les gens qui ont fait ça
il faut les condamner c'est très grave
il faut trouver les coupables
il faut trouver des coupables et palais
des papes tuer des innocents
ouais j'espère qu'ils vont trouver les
coupables et les mois à venir et les
punir un truc exemplaires ça c'est clair
et net et je me sens pas du tout non
plus avec moi je suis de confession
musulmane mais je crois qu'on n'a pas le
même le même livre avec banane est
désolé on n'a pas la même religion
le problème est que ça c'est pas le
problème je comprends un peu ce qu'ils
veulent dire ces gens là c'est bush tout
à coup on en fait une personne super
sage ou presque on va lui donner le prix
nobel de la paix est ce qu'on va les
donner le prix nobel de la paix alors
que quand même je crois que dan à manger
parce qu'il ya des milliers d'exemples à
donner mais je crois qu'il n'a pas signé
les accords de kyoto mais on peut dire
c'est bon on peut le dire il a fasciné
les accords de kyoto
il n'a pas fait grand chose pour établir
la paix en au moyen-orient dix ans entre
israël et la palestine on peut lui
reprocher beaucoup de choses bien sûr
mais surtout qu'ils ont les moyens de
surtout la base dans les moyens de de
l'essayer israël à côté à israël ici
avoir un terrain territoire pour la
palestine et puis vivre ensemble et puis
voilà qu'on arrête avec c'est justement
arrivé en israël mais moi je viens pas
me faire de la politique je trouve que
c'est un sujet très compliqué qui datent
pas de 48 ni d'hyères cette date de
d'abraham
ils se mêlent et isaac et je pense que
si c'est pas trop ici enfin je pense pas
que ce serait ici qu'il faudra en parler
beaucoup parce qu'il s'agit de la paix
dans
mais si on se mobilise nous pour
encourager ceux qui marchent vers la
paix plutôt que de ce fait ce que
d'encourager ceux qui mettent de l'huile
sur le feu dans notre responsabilité
vous tous les jours parce que vous allez
dire vous avez dit hélas pas les citer
là c'est déjà pas vrai donc c'est parce
qu'ils ont vécu un moment donné aux 10e
11e siècle à l'époque de l'andalousie où
ils vivaient ensemble à merveille tout
se passait bien je comprends pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui en algérie il y
avait des trois communautés qui vivait
ensemble ça se passe et ses colères mais
ça a toujours existé tu vois ça a
toujours existé ça c'est possible mais
est-ce que les ceux qui ont le monopole
impôts qui domine le veulent vraiment je
sais pas simplement je pense aux ces
gens là les terroristes je crois que ça
il ya quand même des siècles de frustrer
des siècles peut-être pas mais de
frustration de la part de ces gens là et
pour en arrière pour en arriver à ça il
faut vraiment que ce soit une
désespérance terrible pour en arriver à
dire un mec bombe à toi tu vas aller
prendre un avion tu vas tu es 7000
personnes
toi tu vas machin toi tu vas faire ça
c'est terrible quand même parce que
j'essaye pas de lait qu'on prend fin si
j'essaye un peu de les comprendre mais
il ya quand même des questions qu'il
faut se poser aussi il n'ya pas les
méchants et les gentils non pas les
méchants c'est ce qui tue quand même il
faut se demander pourquoi ils font ça
c'est imaginable
les espoirs du mec quand même enfin pour
arriver à tuer d'autres gens fin et puis
en plus ce qui est terrible c'est que en
israël il ya un mec qui se tuer pour
blesser deux ou trois personnes
maintenant ils sont aperçus que si la
composante 7001 c'est grave lors islam
que dieu nous préserve un jeu sans en
avoir extrait enfin moi personnellement
et je connais beaucoup de gens mais rien
à voir et de non respect de la femme non
respect d'avoir des gens comme ça les
traités comme des animaux tout ça tout
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'islam nous
c'est nous ça ressemble c'est ressembler
à la torah est la bible à 12 ans un
testament c'est venu pour parachever ces
religions et ça parle d'amour de
tolérance de fraternité
2 il y avait incité après un proverbe
lula a dit comme on dit de prophètes qui
disait nouvelle pac entre musulmans vous
êtes des frères mais que les autres ce
sont vos frères dans l'humanité ouais on
est tous frères dans ce monde n'y a pas
deux et on est contre contre la guerre
contre quand tu d'une personne c'est
comme si tu allais l'humanité donc c'est
tout ce bois
[Applaudissements]
c'est très important que c'est très
important que lui dit ça dans une
émission de télévision comme ça comme la
beauce vers ce que parce que la france
pour moi c'est essentiel c'est une
république laïque et la laïcité pour moi
c'est une valeur essentielle de notre
république parce que c'est à la fois une
protection de nos libertés individuelles
certaine liberté de conscience de croire
ou de ne pas croire
il croit quelque chose je crois
différemment mais on se respecte
et c'est l'essai du domaine de la sphère
privée et il faut que ça reste d'un
domaine de la sphère privée et donc la
laïcité ça protège ses libertés
individuelles et en même temps c'est une
règle de vie en commun c'est parce qu'on
se respecte qu'on peut vivre ensemble
mais je pense est une vraie valeur vraie
valeur il parlait tout à l'heure avec
pierre arditi
c'est vrai qu'après l'attentât du world
trade center
tout le monde était très très énervé
comme ça en france si c'est normal et
c'est effroyable ce qui s'est passé puis
les jours passant les semaines passant
ont l'impression quand même
qu'aujourd'hui les gens en france
l'opinion publique en france commence à
prendre en compte effectivement ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
palestine l'irak etc
est-ce que question simple est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une attitude
raisonnable ou une attitude munich oise
honnêtement que les français aujourd'hui
se pose des questions qui débattent sur
ces problèmes de paix de développement
d'inégalités international de laïcité
j'y tiens j'en disais un goût tout à
l'heure et qui se posent des questions
et qui s'inquiète devant l'éventuelle
engrenage mais moi ça me va très bien
avant qu'on veut qu'on en parle plutôt
que de suivre comme ça les yeux fermés
des gens qui vous diraient fait si fait
ça on va voir comment non je dis on est
en démocratie c'est des sujets très
grave très sérieux plus on en parlera
plus on s'interrogera mieux ça vaudra
mais une annonce l faut pas que cette
interrogation nous amène à une
résignation
bien sûr quand la région lacombe a cramé
la combattre depuis avec ou pas
maintenant voilà sûr et après il faut
faire très attention il comprit busch a
dû faire des machines arrières pas ce
qu'il a dit des bêtises et il n'était
pas le seul
les mots ont un sens et les mondes non
seulement un sens mais une importance
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
il s'agit de faire justice pas vengeance
là
justice oui mais pas la vengeance il
s'agit de faire justice et pas des
croisades pas des guerres de religion
pas de guerre d'une civilisation quand
une autre ça moi je ne marche pas la
justice oui parce que ces moines des
choses qu'on punisse des barbares sirène
pour finir j'ai l'impression que vous
pensez là vous dites ils sont ici sont
en france ils sont tranquilles c'est la
paix
et puis l'histoire d'israël appel si moi
je veux qu un etat palestinien
je ne suis pas contre un état
palestinien je pense qu'on peut pas nous
vivre dans des dents des dents des
belles maisons et mieux vivre dans des
caniveaux je suis d'accord avec ça mais
le problème c'est de savoir pourquoi
évident et caniveaux et comment on peut
aider sassine si arafat il est
milliardaire ce qui est vrai pourquoi il
est pas son peuple pourquoi
j'ai 18 ans là ma mère qui n'est pas
juif qui est venue en israël qui a vu la
première chose qu'il m'a dit m'a dit
mais mais qu'est ce que c'est c'est
trucs sur les immeubles heures jeudi de
quoi tu parles et je vois qu'elle
regarde les plaques qui disent donner
des de bail des gens dans le monde
entier jeudi passé des gens qui ont aidé
pour faire des écoles les universités
les trucs des machins parce qu'ils
étaient juifs dans le monde entier qui
ont été généreux mais c'est quand même
la population arabe est quand même très
nombreux s'il donnait un franc même
position il dit au lieu des ben laden
elle ferait mieux d pour aider pour
l'éducation parce qu'ils ont pas d c'est
vrai moi je viens je sais qu'il faut aux
réseaux de ce problème le problème c'est
dans l'éducation il faut qu'ils aient
des écoles faut qu'ils aient des
établissements faut pas qu'ils voient
nous dans des dents des bêtes dans des
grands bâtiments et eux dans la merde ça
je sais et c'est on peut pas on peut pas
accepter ça en tant qu'humain s'il faut
savoir c'est quand même qu'ils seraient
là aider les palestiniens à aider pour
qu'ils se construisent parce qu'on sait
qu'on peut pas dealé avec des gens faire
des ddd promis des accords sans que je
sois prêt donc les établissements la
police de machin on les a formés on a
même donné des armes pour qu'ils
puissent se défendre
maintenant ils tirent sur nous donc il
ya plein de choses qu'on sait pas pour
moi le monde y vit en deux il ya les
bons et les cons
merci djamel bouras vous restez avec
nous
j'accueille maintenant alexandra lamy et
jean dujardin
m
c'est intrigant c'est incroyable alors
vous êtes pour ceux qui ne savent pas
encore est le héros d'un gars une fille
et prom qui programme de sept minutes
diffusé depuis deux ans sur france 2
avant le 20h
et c'est vrai que les présentateurs du
journal télévisé valls sur france 2 mais
vous vous êtes toujours là chaque soir 5
millions de téléspectateurs suivent des
aventures de souche ou et loulou un
jeune couple que vous incarnez qu'ils
sont ensemble depuis sept ans lui c'est
vous ouais vous êtes plutôt machos casey
nier dragueur jaloux tendance infidèle
colérique fans de foot et de bagnols
ouais hein c'est vous vous êtes coquine
coquette pipelette accro au shopping et
au sexe oui jalouse mais tendance
fidèles vous voilà oui alors le
programme dans le connaît c'est une
succession de petites saynètes
entrecoupées d'un habillage très
chouette très très branché 1
la série est issu d'un concept québécois
mais elle explose dans tous les pays
d'europe où elle est adaptée
alors évidemment pour ceux qui
connaissent pas on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble mal aux destinations quoi tu
m'as trahi
qui regarde ma femme l'a fort
le débat est parfois je me plains pas
mieux pour les filles sexy y aura des
campings ajoie non je trouve pas
[Musique]
un gars une fille
soit sur moi
ils sont allés sens
nous savons comment on fait parce que ce
week-end
alors alex est né à alès oui vous rêviez
étant petit de devenir gardienne de
chèvres sait vraiment comment vous savez
ça oui et puis ensuite formation de
théâtre classique au conservatoire de
nîmes et en 92 vous débarquez à paris
pour des auditions vous commencé le
théâtre les téléfilms vous êtes évincée
du casting d'un gars une fille départ à
cause d'un mauvais partenaire pour
redemander une chance et cette fois
c'est jean c'est un mec et il a dit à la
productrice
c'est une nana qui pourrait me faire
donc ça c'était décision
[Applaudissements]
ouais il a dit isabelle camus saint paul
à prendre parce qu elle vraiment j'ai
envie de me la taper sinon j'en remets à
rueil malmaison
après le bac et le service militaire
deux ans serrurier dans le bâtiment
ouais ça apprend la vie ça non ouais
ouais j'ai des comics en bâtiment le mic
en bâtiment et le soir one man show dans
des cafés théâtres et puis membre de la
bande du carré blanc est là un jour
jean dujardin déniché par stéphane
calvet le directeur artistique de
l'émission vous faites graines de stars
way et vous gagner trois fois de suite
ouais c'est vrai j'ai le record chaque
fois vous arrivez plus jamais ça et vous
vous y retournez quand même ouais c'est
vrai c'est super souvenir quoi c'était
c'était fabuleux
super pétoche mais bien content mais
c'est là on s'est rencontré d'ailleurs
voilà et on va voir avec quoi vous avez
gagné mais aussi du don
[Musique]
salut salut ça va ça farte ça farte
bombe
welcome sur la plage de lacanau beach je
me présente je m'appelle brisse julien
de nice de nice tu sais comment elle
m'appelle les familles six mois le
sniper
je suis harcelé la journée je me cache
dans la baraque à frites obligé de surf
et la nuit à la bougie
mais la nuit c'est les sirènes qui me
gonfle non attendez attendez je veux
dire c'est dur d'être un canon je le
souhaite à personne
en plus moi le style blondasse plastique
féline et je vais te dire ça me laisse
rêveur
d'ailleurs si une pitchouns dans le
groupe un peu raboteuse qui aiment le
gall ac
rendez vous ce soir en camping des
vaniteux emplacement de l demande brice
rois de la glisse
[Applaudissements]
les serveurs mais alors là nous décider
avec avec vos copains de l'époque la
bande du carré blanc de créer une troupe
de faire les nous c nous et qui fait ça
c
d
grandeur
car elle est nulle c'est nous
beaucoup d'émissions de télévision des
parodies sur france2 d'ailleurs souvent
est alors en 99 il avait le camus la
productrice et le pense d'abord à josé
garcia pour un gars une fille puis voilà
il était pris par le cinéma et c'est lui
qui a suggéré votre nom oh ouais c'est
ça c'est vrai mais c'est bien sûr c'est
vrai ah oui j'irai à reculons au départ
ouais parce que j'étais en train de
repeindre la chambre de mon fils et puis
moi les castings c'est pas elles sont
pas super bien quoi donc
elle m'a appelée puis elle m'a montré
les les vidéos des canadiens donc et
puis ça m'a plu
vous avez vu cinq filles et puis la 6e
c'était c'était alex ouais ouais ouais
puis c'est passé tout de suite enfants
nous ont vite délire et on avait même
débit un grande complicité tout de suite
wen s'est rapidement fait ce qu'il dit
en parlant de vous et c'est mon pote
avec des seins en même temps c'est sympa
et pas sympa oui justement alors j'ai
des problèmes avec vos conjoints
respectifs
il paraît qu il vous embrasse plus
souvent que votre jules non c'est pas
vrai d'abord c'est thierry ardisson
c'est à peu près équivalents à temps
richard élégant
l'origine d'organiser un dîner ah c'est
vrai oui on s'est rencontré deux coups
pour être sûr qu il y avait passé des
trucs à 4 quoi après après quoi les
cathares joie
je suis tout seul
ils l'attendent
[Musique]
j'accueille inquiète maintenant
enfin comme cette chandelle oui à peu
près à peu près leur et 32 ans est
marseillais auteur compositeur
producteur leader du groupe iam et aussi
d'autres disques en solo sous votre nom
propre
alors sortez un deuxième album qui est
votre deuxième album solo chez hostile
c'est comment on fait comment j'ai un
problème au bras là alors on revient
deux fois
allez-y je voulais faire c'est comment
on fait une petite main comme ça
[Applaudissements]
à vernon arrêts
c'est pourquoi je vais pas et je suis en
tout temps des missions réparties du
comité avec baffie à témoin et ramifié
des réseaux dormants et son nez très
organisé j'ai le disque
[Applaudissements]
et alors six ans après [ __ ] et mat
vous sortez un album qui s'appelle sol
invictus le premier single ses
impressions extrait de son habitus
impression par akhenaton alors salut
personne me dit qu il ya soleil
invincible pourquoi ces symboles symbole
payen non c'est un symbole c'est sympa
ces mots le
romain mais en fait c'est plus pour dire
en fait un symbole païenne qui
retournait pour pour être un symbole en
fait de croyance le soleil est
invincible
le soleil est une création de dieu du
est invincible ouais j'avais bien ce que
vous savez quand même qu'il y aurait des
ss qui défilait sous le symbole il y
avait des ss qui définissent ou symboles
plus que ça c'était c'est un peu le côté
obscur qui dans ce qu'il ya dans l'album
que je décris dans ce morceau que sa
position puisqu'il ya un côté de sa vie
que tu ce que je défends un côté que je
condamne et dans des paroles du morceau
qui s'appelle j'aime jeudi mais à
travers des pages je compris que n'est
pas trois sont les noirs et ait lui même
temps on le doit à la croix il faut pas
vous le savez que ces voix là alors il
ya une vraie dichotomie entre le titre
de l'album le soleil est invincible et
puis le ton un petit peu nostalgique
presque désabusé des paroles non oui de
la nostalgie de l'amertume nostalgie
vis-à-vis de l adolescence amertume
vis-à-vis de de relations amicales ou de
vision du coeur
que j'ai sur l'europe maintenant alors
quand vous étiez jeune vous habitiez à
marseille à plan de cuques à la sortie
de marseille votre mère qui vous a élevé
avec votre frère fabien qui est devenu
votre manager aujourd'hui et à l'époque
vous appelait encore philippe fragione
parce que vous êtes petit fils d'immigré
napolitain calabrais et une chansons
albums y verront une chanson qui pèse
way qui parle de ce à quoi le pays
alors notre mère employés d'edf divorce
et militants de syndicalistes cgt et
vous sécher tes magnifiques les haut
parleurs
je pense qu'elle tenait pas le haut
parleur mais elle a été pas mal ça
qu'est dans l'entreprise enfin edf parce
qu'elle a été militante
je pense qu'elle a perdu ses illusions
je suis désolé avec le socialisme peut
qui a qui était une sorte de deux pintes
et maquillés de la gauche socialiste et
finissent toujours par sauver la
bourgeoisie finalement exactement je
pense que la nature vous si j'ai plein
de choses à dire la combinaison elle est
là non non mais je ça fait partie des
débats publics non mais je comprends il
ya des supers d'histoire de la gauche et
pas que des pas que des triomphes et
c'est aussi des échecs et même sans
doute des souffrances pour des militants
je le comprends très bien votre mère à y
croyez quand elle a vu l'arrivée
mitterrand elle a sauté la sotetel a
sauté de sa chaise hachette est tombé
tout le monde chez moi sauter je suis
d'une famille rouge mois de 1,2 à z donc
ils ont sauté
ils sont retombés je retombe mais depuis
qu'ils sont passés en dessous de la
table 1 alors à l'école vous dit j'étais
un insoumis
c'est un terme très fort pour
interrompre la peau d'habitude pour
l'armée mais ce soit david entier vous
étiez pas à turbulent non pas du tout je
pense que j'étais plutôt insoumis dans
ce qu on nous obligeait à faire qui me
semble injuste du genre les cantons et
demi le samedi après midi le mercredi
après midi avec des interros
obligatoirement chaîne a aucune parce
que j'ai jugé que mercredi après midi
c'était pour nous reposer bien lors des
deux chocs culturels dans votre enfance
d'abord quand votre mère vous achète une
encyclopédie pour enfants vendus en
porte à porte qui s'appelle tout
l'univers en 24 volumes c'est le choc
vous découvrez ou redécouvrez les
dinosaures d'abord vous découvrez
l'egypte ancienne ccdh ou akhenaton
d'ailleurs toutes les civilisations
antiques d'ailleurs g7 ainsi copie
qu'ils étaient drôlement bien fait
puisque pour les enfants y avait
beaucoup dit d'image et je sais pas si
c'est du fait de peu de la période de
séparation de mes parents je les lui du
1er au 21 ème volume et donc là vous
flashez sur akhenaton serviteur du
disque solaire qui est qui était en fait
un pharaon l'époux de néfertiti je peux
pas prendre part dont tu vas avoir un
truc si bien qu'une hâte on y trouve ça
bien c'est là qu'on attend c'est
passionnant c'est le premier qui a
introduit le culte monothéiste en egypte
ont rencontré qu'intelligente
tout le monde sait ça
on va
lui a succédé toute entière c'est pas
ces machines on râle car qui lui alors
parce que le pays s'était un peu délité
avec akhenaton faut dire la vérité est
donc tout en cas mon vous pouvez sortir
il a toujours eu en main toutankhamon
haut et enfin sous l'impulsion du clergé
de tableau et du clergé de thèbes
absolument les inspections service
unique situé à michel on apprend des
trucs quand même attention le 2 risque
de basculer 1,5 alors premier choc
culturel donc on l'a dit c'est tout
l'univers deuxième choc culturel
quelques années plus tard vous découvrez
le rap en écoutant émission qui
s'appelle starting blacks sur radio
starz et 13 ans 180 justement et la
radio est installé sur les hauteurs de
marseille dans une bergerie flotteurs de
marseille et vous l'avez racheter
aujourd'hui vous allez installer votre
studio de dans quoi on va gérer la
boucle est bouclé la boucle est bouclée
on est en a un à nos bureaux nos studios
dans ce vieux la chose qui est magique
parce que c'est clairement et les
émissions
qu'ils montrent qu'ils m'ont mis dans
cette musique qui était mise de sérieux
là ce lieu mythique puisse carrément
colucci annoncé dès le début des
restaurants du coeur il ya madonna qui
est venu donc celle du chargé d'histoire
même si c'est une bergerie alors en
france à marseille
en france assez chaud devant un quartier
assez chaud un jour il ya un mec qui dit
à un de vos copains je ressemble à
fernandel c'est vrai ça le mec il est
monté il a pris un fils je suis
redescendu de la tuer ouais ouais bah
même métier
[Musique]
mais merci mort c'est aller en
s'améliorant
le marseille de mes 12 ans et s était
plus plus agité que maintenant mais
n'ont cessé ces cas mais bon on peut y
aller en prison
bon alors là vous partez à new york un
vous partez à brooklyn dans la famille
de votre père vous resté deux ans et
demi là bas et là c'est la découverte
effectivement du hip hop du rap est
assez folklorique énorme
là bas vous avez été en contact avec
tout ce que le hip hop compte de
l'époque - et surtout les artistes des
années d'or du hip hop 87 4 et 8 mois à
vous revenez un jour un je suis votre
père cette fois qui responsables
informatiques à la la sécurité sociale
et au moment de passer le bac et une
anecdote là qui vous qui vous résume
assez bien qu'elle attend au monde
passait le bac est agacé d'attendre
devant la porte de l'examinateur et vous
vous sauver vous échouez au foot et
quand vous racontez ça où je perds et
bibi du monde devant la porte du monde
devant la porte
on trouvera toute ta vie et vous
dites-vous suite à ça cette réflexion
m'a appris à pas vouloir passer devant
les autres mais a cassé la porte
je pense que j'aime bien parce que quand
on a fait du rap
quand on a fait cette musique il en a
l'habitude de voir les portes se
refermer devant soi et puis les portants
c'est pas un cliché mais on apprend à
les ouvrir tout seul et à plusieurs
qu'on a dû casser et même toujours
maintenant puisque un artiste rap est
toujours doit lutter sans cesse contre
ces clichés mais chaque fois j'ai
l'impression que chaque fois qu'on
ressort que quoi que ce soit il faut
toujours expliquer mais c'est vrai
capitalise pas cantonné quand on est un
artiste de hip hop on capitalise pas sur
une carrière vous passer le bac d en
candidat libre docks de biologie et puis
après vous
être archéologue évidemment à cause de
l'egypte vous êtes indiana jones mais
vous dites je me suis arrêté à ça c'est
drôle à la fin vous dites je me suis
arrêté à la table des joueurs de cartes
à la cafétéria y avait des magnifiques
baby foot et les très belles tables avec
des très bons joueurs de belote contrée
donc ma maman ma carrière scolaire assez
et arrêter ce carnage et la voilà en à
votre père vous dites monsieur faire du
rap tu te démerdes est d'ailleurs dans
sol invictus est une chanson qui
s'appelle le fiston c'est un petit peu
l'histoire d'un père qui a peur pour son
fils êtes-vous aujourd'hui ça va vous
arriver parce que votre fils yanis quand
il va avoir 15 ans il faut pas bien non
un panneau continuer ses études
notamment quand il est en âge de décider
ce qui ce qui me il fera strictement ce
qui lui plaisait tant au niveau de sa
carrière je pense que s'il part pas en
vrille comme on dit tout va bien
prescilla des ambitions j'aime pause
rien aux enfants même nom mais sur un
plan des croyances et tous âges et un
petit peu faut dire la vérité
c'est un petit peu parti en vrille après
cette époque là c'est les années zone
les années un petit peu galère vous dit
tellement abîmée de l'intérieur j'ai
perdu cinq ans de ma vie à rester assis
en insultant le monde entier en croyant
que c'était la faute des autres
alors été comme hiver vous étiez au
métro vieux port comme à résidence
tellement hostiles à cet endroit là
qu'un jour il ya la bonne femme de
l'office du tourisme
elle leur donne une boîte de chevet lui
dans une boîte de chocolats il suffit
plus elle m'a pris pour un clochard et
là ça vous a fait réfléchir je crois que
le réveillon du jour de l'an là je dis
il faut faire quelque est quand même
quelque chose là
croit elle contente pas de déchets verts
on va faire quelque chose et la voilà
tout s'est mis en marche
musique maïs blanc
pas plus
les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la vie est belle le destin sans des
cartes
personne ne joue avec les mêmes cartes
il a fait quoi la nhtsa je veux voir le
cantus ans passés aux victoires de la
musique c'est trop fort
serge s'il te plaît aiello leur culte
dans tout juste un truc que l'a voulue
édifiant
[Musique]
lebel
ces chiens guides à cette version 6 gdi
du virage pris les conséquences qu'il
délivre un film social libre soit une
alerte qui se démarque pas de bol pour
beat box n'est pas sûr d'aller voir ce
film est bonne comme ça oui
sur france 2 à 20
mais plus jamais revenu
on n'est plus jamais revenu et c'était
vous dirais que là c'était bien on
continue ma mémoire comme le château où
sortent les temps tard
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est benza brydon la musique
du film comme un aimant permanent
aujourd'hui j'ai joué mon père s'est
laissé le moment aujourd'hui j'ai juste
une pression si la vérité
alors vous êtes converti à lui à oui
c'est bien ça vous êtes converti à
l'islam en 92
peu avant votre mariage avec aïcha
pourquoi tout simplement
qu'est ce que savent plus l'islam par
rapport à cateau c'est une heure réforme
l'islam est la dernière des religions
c'est la suite logique de du judaïsme du
catholicisme et l'islam est allé la
réforme puisque en fait le dernier des
prophètes qui s'appelle mohamed est venu
pour réformer la religion catholique
avant pour nous la différence se situe
au simple fait que jésus n'est pas mort
sur la croix
1 voilà il n'a pas été crucifié la été
substituées explique la non il a été
substitué n'est pas mort sur la croix et
les mort ans selon selon nous un
soixante et dix en egypte donc voila
vous plaignez beaucoup en france par
exemple vous dit un jour dans un train
vous avez gueuler contre le contrôleur
parce qu'il y avait que des sandwichs
jambon par exemple vit dans un pays où
il ya des juives où il ya des musulmans
c'est quand même un drame c'est que
décent de 13 des brevets de cri depuis
12 heures et il prévoit des sandwichs
pour les passagers et jeudi c'est quand
même dramatique que dans un pays où il
ya 10% ou 12% des gens qui ne mangent
pas de porc on peut voir que des
sandwichs jambon
c'est ce genre d'outil de petits trucs
qui relate bien l'esprit de fond qui est
que dans les pays anglo saxons certes de
communautarisme est pas la solution
idéale et nous on n'a pas la bonne
solution non plus je pense que c'est la
solution se trouve entre les deux c'est
par une intervention et par
l'intégration et contre l'intégration
encore moins pour la simulation
parce que ce qu'on veut en france et
faire une assimilation c'est pas
l'intégration qu'on veut c'est la
république ça
jean glavany a c'est à dire que c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu réducteur la
république c'est à dire que tout le
monde doit séparer du kt la cie n'ont
pas public c'est l'intégration
l'assimilation quand les lois de la
réputation lesquels ne sont pas
réductrice aînés oppressive elles sont
libératrices au contraire et protectrice
et moi j'ai le jeu autant je comprends
la révolte contre la contrebande du
train contre l'option de match au jambon
donc j'y ai cru comprendre qu'ils
avaient quand même un peu de révolte il
ya un peu de révolte ans je pense que
c'est parce que notre esprit notre
époque n'est pas encore assez laïque
oui exactement on va de la place à
toutes les religions voilà voilà
elle est au bout de mon raisonnement moi
je considère qu'une république qui ne
permet pas à 12% des siens de pratiquer
leur religion au grand jour qui les
oblige à le faire dans des caves ou dans
des hangars qui y compris à paris après
faut pas s'étonner que ceux qui sont
frustrés se révoltent ou le fasse d'une
manière violente et la vraie laïcité
c'est pas d' empêcher de croire c'est de
permettre à tout le monde de croire en
liberté et en tolérance c'est pour cela
que je dis dans le même truc un miracle
quand on a quand les américains ont
décidé l'embargo il aurait été bien plus
fort de donner à manger la population
avec des gros sacs avaient marqué usa
dessus et les gens se seraient plus
facilement retourner contre le régime le
sait rater la senator voir je vous salue
voilà bientôt et bravo merci
on attend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant daniel picouly
et un bigot les bons soirs soir 85 kg 1
m 85
on vous compare souvent à julien clerc
mais j'avais la même même origine en
fait
carteron martiniquais tous deux voient
là et on vous prend souvent pour un
arabe c'est sympa bouillon septembre bah
c'est à dire c'est justement à partir du
11 septembre
on se pose des petites questions quand
on a une gueule comme la mienne et qui
effectivement une gueule d'arabe et j'en
suis très fier ouais et les gens dans la
rue et des fois vous sentez un mois j'ai
partagé pas bien sûr comme on dit
comme on dit toujours je vais lui encore
al arab et oui pas de toi tu as de la
chance était de français moi non mais on
est souvent il ya plein de gars qui le
dit justement mais faute à pas vraiment
une gueule d'arabe jsais pas c'est pas
toi qui nécessita une gueule d'arabe
cédé quatre gars qui descendent avec des
battes de base-ball ceux qui
décideraient alors vous êtes né en 48 à
vide monde dans la seine saint denis
vous êtes 11e d'une famille de treize
père martiniquais mère morvan diotte en
france d'un pavillon minuscule et puis
ensuite en 62 hlm à en lire là d'un coup
cela c'est la grande vie qui commence
bah oui parce que c'était un rêve c'est
quelque chose qu'on a du mal à imaginer
m'annoncer que les hlm c'était bien
ordinaire les talents plein écran une
baignoire c'était un rêve
absolument extraordinaire à dire ça bien
sûr il faut il faut le dire il faut le
savoir
bon maintenant malheureusement je peux
pas retourner sur les lieux de mon rêve
parce qu'on l'a rasée comme ça c'est
comme ça se passe souvent comme parmi
vos copains adolescents à certains ont
fini à fleury mérogis ouais vous dites
moi je m'en suis sorti parce que je
pourrai plus vite que les autres
oui mais c'est aussi je dois ça beaucoup
à ma gueule c'est à dire souvent quand
les gags visuels où nous le sommes je
courais je courais ont entraîné ça m'a
beaucoup aidé à l'adolescence pour
justement échapper et puis aller du bon
côté c'est à dire grasset flammarion
plutôt que fleury mérogis et fresnes
vous n'avez pas de ressentiment pascal
écoles en étiez à l'école pendant la
guerre d'algérie donc sur les pas être
facile quand même mais justement et gt
gt à cette époque là dans l'est dans les
années 50-60 où il y avait les arabes
dehors alors effectivement ce n'est pas
tellement de ressentiment parce que vous
êtes arrière arrière petit fils
d'esclave
mais vous dites je vais pas présenter la
note tous les matins coordonnant et
j'aimerais pas du tout justement qu'on
s'en tire avec ça c'est en ce moment il
ya il ya un débat il faudrait payer et
j'aimerais pas un jour recevoir par la
poste un chèque de 6 francs 75 pour
solde de tout compte dans sa gamme à
tétouan on a payé ça j'ai moi même alors
scolarité pas terrible non non non mais
cancre heureux mais cancre orientation
vers la compta et heureusement il ya la
lecture qui vous souffle et alors c'est
très marrant parce que lecture arrive
très tôt dans votre univers et et grâce
au livre de poche
oui et vous dites comme je connaissais
rien j'ai acheté les numéros mauvais non
mais je croyais qu'il fallait lire dans
l'orb
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé la symphonie
pastorale mais j'ai jamais trouvé le
premier tennisman
je le regrette encore comment alors mai
68 c'était assas j'écrivais un premier
roman non-publié fait une maîtrise de
gestion à dauphine oui ensuite et dans
le quartier ensuite à saignant maître
auxiliaire dans les lycées de banlieue
puis prof pour bts en force de vente est
votre premier roman publié si la lumière
des fous c'est bizarre j'ai écrit ça
parce que c'est une histoire
d'adolescentes enceintes par un prof qui
avortent dans les toilettes parce que
c'est une histoire quasiment vécu
c'était un mois j'ai été surpris quand
on entend ces histoires là de temps en
temps j'ai une copine de classe qui
demande à sortir
ouais elle sort on a pris quelques temps
après qu'elle avait avorté dans l'est
dans les toilettes et elle est revenue
mais moi j'ai toujours été sidéré 1 par
le courage un courage et le fait qu'on
n'ait rien vu mais moi quelques années
plus tard j'ai été prof et un jour je
fais l'appel il manque une grasse y est
andy même si vous n'êtes pas au courant
elle a eu un bébé elle a été six mois
devant moi un train reste comme ça mais
je m'en suis pas aperçue alors après la
série noire vous écrivez bouquin je
crois la série noire et puis l'avons
rencontré françoise verny effectivement
vous passez du côté téléphone comme tout
le monde connaît du soda son ailier de
la ville au chéri chéri
poussé à écrire un livre s'appelle le
chan chan de personnes chez flammarion
en 95 énorme succès 500000 exemplaires
oui c'est ça ou un truc incroyable
consacrer à votre mythologie familiale
c'est à dire vos parents peut l'être
j'ai tout ça vraiment et votre vie
réalité sociale mais à partir du bonheur
jours
oui c'est ça c'est curieusement c'est là
même la même année où il sortit la haine
ouais bon moi c'était le logis passait
pas le contrepoint mais il y avait deux
voies pour pour s'intéresser à ce qui se
passait en banlieue et avec le chant de
personnes et puis voilà il y avait la
haine alors deuxième roman dans la même
veine un qui s'appelle fort de l'eau qui
racontent des vacances en algérie parce
que votre père a travaillé chez air
france on était chaudronnier cher voilà
c'est ça il travaillait à maison-blanche
alger pour ceux qui connaissent et puis
pour ceux qui connaissent encore mieux
on longe un petit peu la mer on arrive à
fort de l'eau le pays des brochettes là
où il ya des meilleurs prochaine du
monde je le dis parce que c'est la
réalité
voilà alors là les critiques quand même
vous banal un peu ils disent c'est ces
bien pensants c'est effroyablement
sympathique c'est la gauche humaniste
6 la nostalgie baby boom est enfin voilà
quoi il trouve que c'est du marketing
oui et non c'est ça c'est à dire que le
bonheur vite on a l'impression qu'on l'a
fait exprès on devrait s'excuser d'avoir
été heureux puissant fort est on a envie
de dire aux gars les montres nous un
petit malheur enfin les parents ça
n'allait pas si bien que ça je n'y ai
pas tant que ça quand même bon allez
vas-y
malheureusement je suis désolé mais
c'est comme ça voilà il ya eu ça et puis
a eu ce transfert là vous avez quitté
flammarion pour grasset oui oui quand
j'ai quitté kg qui dit franck voilà j'ai
bon il y avait des sommes qui ont traîné
maison surtout traduire le canard
enchaîné avant moi parce que oui parce
que ça veut dire que j'ai dans mes amis
un petit camarade quelque part qui a
fait comme à une certaine époque qu'à
envoyer une petite lettre me suis je
tiens à vous signaler le cas d'un garçon
qui viennent beaucoup trop d'argent et c
c'est à dire que ça a été sur
dénonciation des nations a envoyé un
corbeau que je connais pas encore son
nom
cherche il était balancé oury bah oui
balance et puis après les journalistes
ont repris ça comme ça ça tombe bien
alors c'était pas mal mais aucune envie
vandelli bien si on va moi j'étais de
ces gosses moi je suis en jet d'une
famille de treize fils d'ouvrier ou le
rêve de mon père s'était payé les impôts
sont longtemps payer des impôts on était
considérée si on n'a pas l'impression
d'être à un parasite mais aujourd'hui je
crois que je rembourse tous les
intéressés que rien perdre en effet
voilà servi alors voilà alors là vous
arrêter un petit peu la saga familiale
en 99 publiés l'enfant léopard qu'est
l'histoire d'un fils mulâtre corée et
marie-antoinette voilà ces bois comme
j'étais au maroc doit être quand j'étais
petit prix relevés n'ont même pas d'eau
hélas aujourd'hui va vous renouez avec
la saga familiale parce que plein de
gens qui vous ont dit bon on l aime bien
l'enfant léopard mais enfin quand même
où est-ce qu'ils en sont on aime bien
marie antoinette mais où on épaulettes
en gros c'est ça il savait comment on
fait oui oui je
là
brave r2
colette épaules interrogés chez grasset
donc dans ce dernier roman vous racontez
votre enfant c'est comme dans le champ
de personnes efforts de l'eau est alors
l'agrément comme vous ai tout raconté
bien vous raconter avant votre naissance
parce que l'asvel avait déjà raconté
quand vous faites pas à chuter oui voilà
physiquement physiquement voilà les deux
ans à c'est un gamin de 12 ans qui se
fait parachuter en 43 5 ans avant sa
naissance dans la vie de ses parents
c'est ça oui mais moi je crois que c'est
le rêve d'un petit peu tout le monde
d'aller voir un petit peu comment
étaient les parents avant qu'on soit né
quoi je crois que ça intéresse ou le
monde voulait voir comment il était
amoureux parce que généralement ses
parents lui rencontre plutôt fatigué
quoi bon autour d'une table le dimanche
soit s'aperçoit quand l'adolescent et
puis on peut pas imaginer que ces deux
là se soit exploser le coeur ce fait
exploser la tête sur exploser le corps a
légué qu'on soit le fruit de ça et on
espère qu'on est le fruit n'a alors moi
je suis allé voir si j'étais bien le le
fruit de la passion ce film permet non
mais c'est passionnant parce que vous
racontez effectivement que votre père
quand il rencontre votre mère enfin
quand roger raconte paulette il ya déjà
elle a déjà beaucoup d'enfants que
j'allais enfin on a revu et ma mère est
veuve avec neuf enfants est mon père est
sur la photo quand on voit on comprend
pas très bien
il a 21 ans là le grand black et à
droite il a 21 ans
c'est le jour de ses 21 ans et la dame
qui est à côté à 28 ans et elle attend
son dixième enfant sur la photo pl comme
sa pleine page est bon alors soit ce
gars est fou soit il était amoureux
c'est un peu les deux et ça ça
m'intéressait beaucoup depuis que je
suis gamin voilà ça s'appelle paul
interrogés c'est chez grasset cette
année
[Applaudissements]
faux
et ça marche plus a marre et comment on
peut recommencer la vie de ses parents
on peut recommencer on a on a tous le
droit parce que mon roman c'est la vie
c'est d'être mes parents avaient un tel
esprit romanesque que ma mère josiane
exemple pas de miser quand le soir on
mange un petit café au lait avec des
tartines c'est qu'il ya pas de sous à la
maison il ya deux solutions et le coup
pape a beaucoup travaillé on n'a pas
assez d'argent
ma mère faisait c'est ce qu'on fait ce
sens les gosses café au lait et toulouse
et ouais super voilà ça s'appelle roman
c'est la vie c'est comme ça qu'elle m'a
élevé et je leur rends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et j'appelle un art by au dessus de tout
soupçon
moi cela fait déborder
[Applaudissements]
tous
m
[Musique]
cette attention j'en rappelle règles du
jeu pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas je
veux le nom des interprètes et pas le
nom du morceau on est bien d'accord
ce soir c'est un spécial poil donc ça
veut dire les chanteurs ou le chanteuse
d'ailleurs ont des bars bondés books ont
des moustaches
alors vous savez que si a soufflé bien
perdre a commencé ça commence maintenant
quoi ton à soufflage il ya des
habillages et un déshabillage kwakwa
didier lumière attention attention en ce
moment ce genre de plaisanterie alors
attention maestro
[Musique]
c'est sheeran avait dit quand j'ai dit
les chanteurs et chanteuses on est des
points des soies lavées dit demis
roussos
mais là vous l'avez dit la lazio au bon
moment c'est cependant un petit bout de
deux sets choses sont didier la
révélation
[Musique]
semblant finalement attention maestro
pas tout jeune
des vacances car le
ça fait deux points pour les serpentins
pzero pour les champagnes
[Applaudissements]
le pêcheur à magrie choix au cas où je
triche un soutien bien on continue m
[Applaudissements]
bah tiens bien plus de matches c'est
bien on continue olivier schultheis
[Applaudissements]
schult un jean schultheis confidence
pour confidence
bravo jean dujardin si monsieur didier
carroll
méline le score 3 à 21 2 pour les
champagnes
attention attention qu'est ce qui se
passe à lyon nantes a bien tourné une de
buman
on continue
monsieur kalfon replay s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
jardin
[Applaudissements]
jean dujardin donc le score est très
serré
ces balles de match la fois par une
superbe en quoi 3 pour les serpentins
enfants ne sont pas dans continue didier
[Musique]
c'est qu'on peut très bien ainsi
ja
et les coûts libre à vous trois points
et serpentins quatre pôles et champagne
l'adorent bac 3 pour les serpentins
didier
[Applaudissements]
elle est là et on ne souffle pas pu
évacuer la salle comment je suis adias
rapide et d'alliances rabhi oui
attention didier zint
enfin qu'à la monnaie
mais oui
elle est gérable
mais on continue aulas j'ai dit ouais
voilà
on commence ici regarde
cette cause un ancien
on continue
[Musique]
j'ai toujours eu du mal en point
non
je m'étais bien on continue divier m
jean ferrat
de toute façon maintenant y'a un truc et
met tout le monde d'accord ça s'appelle
le super banco
l'équipe qui trouve le chemin branco a
tout gagné je sais c'est injuste mais la
vie est un juge donc le super banco tu
peux tout perdre genre
le super banco se fait dans un calme
intégral c'est trop dur patron d'accor
mais ils ont choisi leur champion d'un
côté patrick et l'autre loulou un vrai
j'ai vu didier gotainer ces containers
[Musique]
moi j'ai attendu
à
[Applaudissements]
est un petit peu comme le match de
samedi dernier on est obligé d'arrêter
parce qu'il ya des envahisseurs de
pelouse
ils sont arrivés qu'en dix 10 it up
voilà en tous les cas donc c'est vous
qui allez gagner
bravo les choses
[Applaudissements]
score que ça
ouais
l'émission là
du peuple avec le robin puis sexe
magouille et culture générale
ainsi avec l'ong free au théâtre du
gymnase pierre victime joyeuses pâques
jusqu'au variété jusqu'au 31 décembre
dans notre dame de paris de luc
plamondon et richard cocciante à mogador
jusqu'au 27 janvier
bienvenue à bord ciel patrick sabatier
le temps n'efface pas tout chez anne
carrière et pendant la pub du lundi au
vendredi à 20h35 sur bmc plus
l'intégrale de samedi et la rediff de
minuit djamel bouras merci est venu
témoigner rien si jamel elie semoun
voilà le spectacle commence le 21
novembre donc d'attac lol semoun du 21
novembre au 31 décembre avec une petite
tournée avant une petite tournée après
pepy laquelle sept
elie semoun jean-denis attention
mesdames messieurs politique paul jean
baylet négliger la greenshows de la
pêche politique donne chez grasset merci
jean alexandra lamy et jean dujardin un
gars une fille
de ce coffret vhs et dvd numéro deux en
vente de 7 9 ans
athena temps sol invictus est le single
s'appelle une impression daniel picouly
paul interrogés chez grasset merci
daniel merci beaucoup et puis sortie
elle avait rien
vossen
[Musique]
kato
nov
je vois mes
[Musique]
les babys mois
jusqu'où
et qui
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
c'est mieux
m
non
no
nous
m
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
oh
mon rêve
no
robin
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]